e
good afternoon I request everyone would
take their seats so we can get the
today good afternoon for day two of our
uh public hearings on agency budget
requests and to start off this afternoon
I would like to invite the Secretary of
State and his team up for their
presentation
I don't often begin Mr secretary with
with a compliment but given elections of
judge on turnout and as few as problems
as ever uh you had a very successful
election so thank you for all your hard
work yeah thank you uh we're pretty
proud of the way the election went uh I
don't think I could tell you what date
is right now but uh but the recounts are
going very smoothly and you know we hope
hope to have those done
by next week so it's all good so in
terms of the budget uh this is a
maintenance budget uh the only increases
are um prioriti prioritized needs from
doit otherwise we're sticking within the
the uh parameters that we had last time
you know maintenance
budget and uh yeah we'll go from there
questions you went you not only did your
election go well your presentation was
the briefest one
yet I've had a lot of
practice we have no questions thank you
you okay um following that is the right
is my mic on it is not on if you just
pressed the button in front of you to
the red light that's I'm on now I feel
bad because the Secretary of State's
presentation is going to be shorter than
mine but mine will still be five minutes
you stop me if I if I'm not um uh since
I'm a fairly new agency and although
some of you may know me already I'd like
to tell you a little bit about who we
are I'm Thomas FC the new Hampshire
right to know Ombudsman also known as
the RKO uh as I'm fond of saying I
brought my entire agency with me to
address you here today uh the RKO was
first staffed in uh on July 27 2023 in
the middle of a budget cycle and it
consists of one person that's me uh I've
been New Hampshire attorney since 1986
more than half that time in state
service the law that establishes my
office which is a 2022 Law chapter 250
gives it somewhat competing goals of
providing the public with a simpler less
expensive and faster alternative to the
Superior Court in resolving complaints
under RSA 91a RSA 91a is the access to
governmental records and governmental
meetings and Records law commonly known
as a right to no law so I basically
decide contested cases and I seek to
resolve them informally when I can uh
pursuit of a claim under RSA in superior
court cost several hundred filing a
complaint with my office cost $25
payable to the general fund since the
first day of the office's operation I've
received 254 inquiries of various natur
71 of those became formally filed
complaints they come at an unpredictable
rate and uh more than half are currently
resolved about 40 of those 254 with the
substantial equivalence of right to no
request in my office itself I hear cases
against uh various units of state
government including but not limited to
State executive branch agencies a State
Legislative Branch counties cities towns
school districts and in terms of review
of my activities pursuing to RC 91 a7b
uh 7 yeah 7B 7c uh Appeal on my rulings
as New Hampshire Superior Court and then
potentially up to the Supreme Court so
I'm somewhat between three branches of
government although I'm an independent
executive branch agency I'm attached for
administrative purposes Department of
State and uh when I started this
experimental journey I had a cubicle a
computer space provided by the secretary
of state budget consisting primarily of
my salary and benefits plus a few
thousand in current expenses which ended
up being postage uh I have a statute to
follow and my commission which like my
agency expires on July 1st
2025 the administrative rules of my
office can be found on the office of
legislative services website uh I also
have my own evolving website that's
provided through the Secretary of State
and you can find a current doc of my
scheduled public proceedings links to
the rules and forms of my agency and
links to the office's decisions there uh
and less renewed as I said uh I
currently expire on July 1st 2025
according to my rules my agency's first
and perhaps only annual report is due to
the House and Senate Judiciary
committees the governor of the executive
Council Superior and Supreme Courts on
February 15 2025 for anybody wants to
pay a visit and doors generally open my
office is room 12 in the basement of the
State House Annex which as you may know
is currently under construction what
we're looking at here today is a budget
for what might be after my office ceases
to exist uh my information begins to pay
72 the Secretary of State's budget book
it consists of my anticipated salary and
benefits current expenses which is
mostly paper Postage and such like
supplies is a small amount that's in for
supplies uh for example a lock box for
filings and payments uh I don't
currently have that people the US mail
brings me things puts it on my chair uh
or people come in drop it off by hand uh
perhaps some improved or additional
recording equipment and there's a bit in
this item for uh travel $500 all the
hearings I currently have are in
conquered but I'd like to have the
possibility of holding those hearings on
the road if if it's more convenient to
the parties and I'd like to do that
without my own personal expense uh
there's also about $7,000 for consultant
services with that uh if I continue to
exist I'd hope to retain an individual
perhaps an intern uh a legal intern to
produce what might be called the users
guide in order to better explain my
office make the operations more
conceptually accessible and
understandable perhaps give me some
assistance with uh my administrative
tasks like scheduling and answering
public information
requests uh frankly we could use we uh
could use uh one part-time attorney
Clerk and one part-time administrative
assistant or paralal but I've not asked
for that here there's been $1 placed in
the budget that you're looking at uh for
part-time Personnel in case uh that
should become budgetarily possible at
some point in the future and in the
meantime I continue to serve as the
quasa judicial presiding officer
scheduling clerk administrating research
assistant decision writer rule writer
public information officer and among
other things until such time as the RKO
expires uh fortunately for the state
budget I am an unclassified employee so
there's no overtime that's a factor in
my budget that's all I got that's who I
am any questions I can
answer uh you have a few
questions could you uh approximate how
many either complaints or inquiry you
get and then over the last year and then
how many have been resolved about uh
let's the way I break it down is
inquiries that's people contacting my
office of the uh of the
254 inquiries I've had 71 that became
formally filed complaints coming at an
unpredictable rate don't know when
they're coming uh and uh more than half
of those are currently resolved okay
thank you and to extend your your office
Beyond
July June 30th
2025 uh are you going to make an hb2
request to I I have asked uh a
legislator if you'd be so kind as to uh
put in LSR to extend yes I don't I
haven't seen the bill at this point okay
I I know it's an LSR but I haven't seen
a b okay thank you very much could you
just forward the legislator's name to me
on my email
so the what you said you spoke to A
legislature about putting in an
could you just forward his name to me
his or her name to me on I I I don't
think there's anything you're just
anything private about that I I as the
chair of the Judiciary to do it how
Judiciary I just want to check on it
okay I
think
I'm I think it mentions in your um in
your budget submission that it's Bob
Linn and it's LSR
20257 that would be correct okay
um he's the the current legislation
would would extend as we think the LSR
is drafted extend you for a year um but
you might get extended for two that
doesn't mean I get extended my agency
might get extended I does your do your
term expires as well July 1st
2025 um seems unlikely that if they were
to extend it that they wouldn't extend
you that would be kind of a pain um so
couple of questions um you said that you
would want if the budget uh supported
it um perhaps a part-time clerk Etc kind
of a person I I wonder if if that's the
case if you would mind right it's the
kind of thing we would want to give to
the um the incoming Governor's budget
team so if you could write up something
sort of more formally uh in the form of
a request certainly um that way that way
we're able to catalog any request that
happens to come in I'm not saying
there's going to be money for it but
just so that's there
um and um the basement of the annex we
often refer to as the ground
level it's referred to as many things Mr
Arling housee I uh I'm aware but a lot
of them we can't mention in a public
session I would just point that out as
well thank you it's was good to see you
you next up on the list is the
good afternoon and good afternoon Mr
Gary Senator gray commissioner alen
house and other members of this
committee uh for the record my name is
Chuck seya executive director Governor's
Commission on disability and to my left
is the gcds business administrator um
Miss AC dubia um thank you for the
opportunity uh to present um on our
budget uh by way of backround background
excuse me the governance Commission on
disability is statutorily created uh
pursuant to RSA
275c um within the organizational
structure of the state the gcd is Right
within um the governor's office it is
the commission itself uh right now is
made up of 16 Governor appointed
commission members uh and there also um
ex official members non-voting members
uh which is a cross-section um of state
government um Commissioner of HHS uh
Commissioner of Labor um Commissioner of
Employment Security um doe uh Department
of Education is also at the table with
vul rehab and services for blind and
vision imp as well as the um State uh
Board of Education when we look at the
mission of the gcd and the enabling
statute um it really comes down to the
Americans with Disabilities Act
um as I'm sure you're all well aware um
the Ada ensures non-discrimination um
based upon a disability although we are
not an enforcement agency um I would
state to this honorable committee we we
serve a a pivotal a pivotal um portion
of the state entity when individuals
with disabilities um are are afforded
representation because part of our
mission is to advise the governor the
legislature and the public as relates to
programs and services uh for those with
a
disability um the office is made up of
six full-time um positions and two
part-time positions one of the part-time
positions is currently vacant um however
it is fully funded and we have been
actively um attempting to secure a
candidate in that position um what I
refer to as the accounting units um
there are three major accounting units
at the gcd which would be
one4
one6 and
17 uh one6 is 100% federally funded um
with uh one full-time employee
10007 is predominantly passed through uh
funds that we receive from the Public
Utilities Commission relay Service uh
trust fund which finances um a program
at the gcd known as the
Telecommunications equipment assistance
program as well as news news line for
the blind um regarding the funding that
comes from the Pu and goes to the tep
teap there is a
$3,750 Administration administrative fee
which stays at the gcd for the operation
of that program and ensuring that the
vendor that is selected um carries out
the um requirements some of the program
so the the major Au um for the gcd is 1
004 and to this honorable committee I'm
happy to report that we um did stay
within the targets um that were placed
there obviously we went to every class
and and I know you hear this it's we do
look at the salaries and the benefits
which are typically given which are
given to us and then we just go through
a cross-section of the other classes to
see based upon the FY 24 um actual
expenses based upon the appropriation in
25 and then the target we we actually
you know cut where we could to ensure
that we within the target um the biggest
um cut or the biggest um attempt to
arrive at the Target would be in the um
part-time position so the part-time
position is currently funded at 29 hours
per week um in order to meet the target
we did reduce that to a 23-hour um
position and then we took the overage
and correct me if I'm wrong Stacy
because sometimes you read the numbers
and you read gets blurry the rest of the
the uh uh the prioritized needs request
um that has been requested in this
budget covers the difference between the
the 23 and 29 hours so within that um
compliment we were able to um um stay
within it I would suggest to this
honorable committee um the 29-hour
position will serve um the state well um
the position is known as an 88
coordinator um this was a it is a
request that has a little bit of History
uh going back a few years ago the gcd uh
put together what was known as a
Workforce focus group to to look at um
um the state of New Hampshire as an
employer and to say we want to ensure
that we're a model employer as it deals
with individuals with disabilities um
and in as a Regard in reference to that
um I worked in my team worked very
closely with the division of personnel
and um one of the recommendations that
came out of the workforce focus group is
that in 88 coordinator to sit as a
resource to the rest of state government
when another agency perhaps as a an
individual with a disability they're on
boarding or an individual who is
currently in state government there may
be questions as a revolves around um
accommodations or or other questions
regarding the employment and to have
that person seated at the governance
Commission on disability and we intend
that we would work very closely with
Personnel we would be able um to address
those issues so that's a a very high
level um I'm more than happy to go
further um into the positions if you'd
like to know a little bit more about
that I will tell you um and this is a I
guess an incredible plug for um uh
division of personnel um as you all know
there is a unit over at division of
personnel known as hru human resource
support unit um we have found that to be
an incredibly valuable tool for us um we
went under contract with Hsu
um I think in the last budget cycle um
we also have a um we've also built
hru um into this budget although there's
not a separate class but again within
the targets um I will tell you the HRS
Hsu uh is an incredible tool I would say
especially for smaller agencies and
medium agencies because to deal with the
day-to-day requests um that that that
come up that I may not be able to assist
as quickly or or Stacy may not uh to
have Hsu at the ready is a is a
wonderful uh compliment um to the state
I'll also point out that when we put the
budget together um in Stacy what class
is our rent that we pay class 49 so
class 49 so we're we're up on um
Regional drive so we're sub tenants of
our division of personnel so our rent is
actually paid to personnel and Personnel
is under a third party lease that they
pay to a private landlord uh Great Space
great neighbors but when we built this
budget
we obviously took that um into um
consideration because I I don't I think
uh Personnel may be going through that
process now um so we had to figure out
well if there was going to be an
increase what would that be so we
included that um within that and again
this is um all um within the um Target
that that was there um one of the you
know we have a few programs at the gcd
um and I will tell you a program uh they
came about in 2017 is is known as New
Hampshire's able able Savings Plan able
savings plan allow individuals with
disabilities um to save money tax-free
um without jeopardizing need needs-based
benefits which is supplemental security
income um as well as Medicaid um Federal
legislation was passed in 2014 uh New
Hampshire brought it um in 2016 and uh
the co-administrators of the program per
the statute uh the New Hampshire State
Treasurer Monica mesap LA and myself the
gcd executive director um the able
Savings Program I am going to tell you
straight out is a game changer for
individuals with a disability to be able
to save money without those benefits I'm
being encroached upon um we've operated
with again with with no extra staff uh
from 2017 and without any even General
funds um so it's it has been there are
many many people that are benefiting um
from that program so that is essentially
at the gcd and uh the state Treasury and
it has changed people's lives it's a it
definitely is a um an incredible
resource for individuals um to be able
to live a fruitful life so that's the
gcd at a very high level I'm more than
happy to answer any questions or to go
into further details but I leave that up
to to all of you and thank you again for
this
opportunity in um hi Chuck um hi Chie hi
both of you sorry
um in one4 you have $90,000 of transfer
income what what's that
from you want to address that which
which is it again Char in one4 your main
accounting the one Z4 yes go right ahead
yep go righte I think it's about 90
grand um that's from silk that's um
transfer money from Department of
Education um for the silk program you
want to talk sure great question Charlie
and Stacy excellent excellent um so
essentially um at the gcd we are under
an agreement with the New Hampshire
Department of Education to house a
part-time employee um known as the
Statewide Independent Living Council
program assistant um okay per the
contract with commission with um the
commission of Ed 990,000 is there for is
there for us however we draw Down based
upon our needs so obviously it would be
the part-time salary the benefits um
supervision fees for my self to ensure
that the individual is integrated into
the gcd as well as um uh necessary fees
that are associated with the business
administrator so the 90s there but what
do we typically pull down last year it
was like 70,000 so about 70,000 was last
year that we pulled down okay cool thank
you yeah thanks
Charlie your your funding is is pretty
much all General funds are transfer from
other agencies in one4 that is that is
correct Mr yes okay uh how much federal
funds do you yeah so in
10006 the federal
funding um for FY 26 uh excuse me
26 um
174,175 for FY 26 right I notice that
was had had dropped a little bit from uh
2025 to 2026 six you're anticipated yeah
what's is that correct um if Stacy May
address you yes yes of course um
basically it dropped because we never
spend all that money and technically
we we never know how much we actually
get um because sometimes other states
don't use all their money so that money
comes to us although and we like for
example we were given a certain amount
of money for fiscal year 20 Federal
fiscal year 24 that we haven't even used
yet
and we probably won't use all our money
from fiscal year Federal fiscal year 23
which
closes shortly basically once we have
all our oop sorry um once our rest of
the bills come in for any outstanding
um expenses because it goes it's on a
two-year basis so basically because we
don't really spend that amount of money
we just reduced it a bit and not just
that we we changed a little bit how we
um
the the um amounts for shared funds for
example um the rent it's always been a
certain amount paid by general fund and
a certain amount paid
by um federal funds and so we've changed
that in this federal budget because I I
wasn't sure where those numbers were
coming from so now we are um
basically um based on how much was spent
the previous year what you know the the
grand totals from the pre previous year
which
will change yearly but they don't they
don't change much so we basically
changed how we allocate the shared funds
so if an auditor comes in we can say
this is how we came about these
percentages for General and and federal
funds okay so because you didn't spend
it you didn't request it again right in
your budget that's incredibly
anything else asking any of the
questions thank you very much for your
Tes okay thank you have a nice day and
again thank you for the opportunity
thank
you okay next up is theas Development
Authority
good
afternoon good afternoon my name is
Susie anzelone I'm the finance director
for the peas Development Authority and I
have miles Greenway who's the acting
Port director at the division of ports
and
harbors so um our budgets mainly consist
of salaries and benefits uh we currently
have uh four full-time classified
employees in three-part time we're not
um anticipating any changes in our
staffing some of the budget increases
that you are seeing are really due to uh
future
of our expenses salaries benefits
workers comp all of those things so um
there is no no impact to the general
fund and that's pretty much it unless
you have any
questions uh yes uh the the overtime
line seems to me at least to be quite
High uh I just wonder if you could just
go through and and and why that is yeah
those the numbers that we get and Steve
you can um um Steve mlin if you will
remind me of the where those numbers
come from those come to us from the
payroll Administration and they always
do seem to run higher than what our
actual costs are um and so we don't
anticipate using all of the overtime
funds in there unless something
extraordinary
happens like some really bad storms
again
easy and the board of tax and land
good afternoon good
afternoon my name is Michelle LeBron I'm
the chair of the board of tax and land
appeals and with me is an stalac our
board's clerk also known as an
administrator too which sounds much
better um thank you for this opportunity
to um address you relative to our fiscal
20 26 and 27 budget if you will allow me
I'll speak briefly and then I'm going to
turn it over to miss stelac because she
has some additional
comments the board has four areas of
jurisdiction under RSA 71
B5 which are to hear and determine all
matters involving questions of
Taxation to hear appeals by
municipalities of their equalized
valuation as determined by the
department of Reven Vue
Administration just compensation
processing of imminent domain takings
which includes from the filing date to
having hearings and up to the bidder end
um as determined by RSA
498a and all matters relating to the
need for reassessments for
municipalities you can find a list of
all the statutory matters that are
appealable to the board on pages 11 and
12 of the budget manual and as you will
see we have a lot of
um statutes that are appealable to the
board so we never know from one day to
the next which is going to be
filed this board exists to protect the
rights of the taxpayers and the citizens
of New
Hampshire and um
this is how government runs
and I know we work for the governor and
I fully admit we work for the governor
but I also feel that we work for the
taxpayers of the State of New Hampshire
so we feel very strongly that we protect
those rights and we treat everyone as
they should be
treated we've complied with the
governor's 4% budget cut but at Great
expense in order order to do so we have
had to unfund a review appraiser
position because since 2008 the board
has had continuous staff Cuts we've gone
from a board of 12 to now a board of six
three board members three staff and we
have continually found innovative ways
to modify the workflow efficiencies with
less people but we're at that point now
where we can't find any more efficiency
so our tent our intent in this budget
initially was to seek an additional
position excuse me because of the
increased workload but we heard early on
from the governor
that um funds were tight and you know we
were going to be making Cuts we weren't
be giving money so we didn't even make
do a 70 to to request a new position
so what we had to do in order to meet
the 4% budget was one of two things
either unfund a tax review appraise a
position or zero out all the all the
lines of the
budget that really isn't a choice we we
can't protect the citizens of the state
without any funds at all coming in so
reluctantly we unfunded the review
appraise of position and with that I'll
turn this over to miss stac and then we
will answer any questions you may
have thank you um I'll be brief um I've
been with the board since 2002 and and
as the chair stated we when I arrived we
had eight classified positions and I
have now a staff of two um we currently
have we just had 400 new appeals show up
on the doorstep for over you know and
and we do have 70 different areas of
jurisdiction for three of us to handle
uh we all have a Le legal background but
we have been working very closely with
Personnel to get our positions get them
reclassified so we could get the legal
talent that we need to work on these
appeals before they go to the board
these appeals are complex they take a
lot of time and as Michelle stated we
don't know what's coming in the door any
day
um part of what personnel has really
recommended we've worked with a couple
of the
positions um our plan before we were
told you know to come up with 4% which
again you know it was a choice of give
you back all the operating costs um so
we can't function or we have to give up
a position that what we really wanted to
do was have it reclassified Personnel
said hey you do need more staff we'd
like to take that position and
reclassify it and have it do some of
their appraisal appraiser duties and
then also help um with being working
with me um because in a small office
what happens if if one person is sick
one person's in a hearing and it leaves
one of us alone in a in a building and
it's it's it's happening way too much
the wheels are starting to come off and
what I can tell you is you know when tax
come in I had a woman today I spent an
hour listening to her sob and trying to
figure out okay what is it that you need
how can we help you um and those are the
kinds of things that just you know you
think you have your day planned and in a
small office um we we just don't have
enough bodies and it it sounds really
crass to say that um we have made
efficiency since 2003 we've invested in
software we invested in um a software we
could we contracted for sales and
assessment data then we had to give that
money up so now we've gone back to
manually entering sales data from across
the state because we don't have any
other choice um that was back in 2007 um
we worked with the court the Supreme
Court um Justice bradrick in 2008 he
said hey at the time when I showed up we
had 3,000 cases a year so we've worked
with them on a mediation program we've
gotten it down to um a reasonable number
but 400 is a l that's a lot of cases we
have 700 open rolling every year um and
these cases take a lot of time attention
um for three of us to handle and that's
assuming all three of us are you know
there's nothing else going on that takes
us out of the office or whatever um so
yeah the wheels are starting to fall off
and we really would I I need to keep
this position it needs to be
reclassified um we're happy I
because as Michelle stated I we are very
sensitive and fiscally responsive we are
dealing with taxpayer dollars we
understand that more than anyone um
because we have to hear it day in and
day out and when you hear those stories
um we're not in the business of taking
the precious money that we do have and
wasting it in any fashion we've done
everything we can do
um we used to have two review appraisers
we didn't find the need for that we gave
that was the one position we said okay
we don't need but every other time we
just keep getting chipped away one by
one we're getting picked off and that's
the reality if we lose this and we can't
reclassify it to get us more help um I'm
already neglecting duties and I hate to
say that uh because that shouldn't
happen the taxpayers deserve exactly
what um we have existed since 1911 to do
this work the work doesn't get easier
but there's pieces of my job I I just
can't get to because there's not enough
time and people and all of that and um
and you know not just you know sort of
cry about it but it's I'm just
frustrated and tired of it
so I really want to keep the position so
thank
you I have a a couple of questions uh my
first actually is it's more of a
statement I'm going to go out on a limb
and and and sort of guess that as assess
values rise dramatically the number of
appeals to those assessed valuations
will go up dramatically as well so I
take it you've seen that over the last
few years since we've come out of covid
and assess values in the state have gone
up dramatically um could you do you have
any data as far as the number of appeals
and what they've looked like over the
last few years I yeah mentally I can
tell you absolutely we um during covid
yeah things um um were a little bit
calmer we had less appeals even with
eminent domain the state had stopped
taking land so those went down we would
normally get anywhere we roughly on
average we would the state would we
would end up with about 25ish to 30
takings a year those Dro down to 10 now
we're seeing with the expansion of 4A
we're back with seeing a lot of cases um
and I assume once they come up towards
80 n and fixing conquered that those
we're going to see a lot of that so
those projects generate more work tax
appeals were up this year even compared
to last year by roughly about 50 cases
and that's been the trend for the last
few years
um what we're seeing now is increased
exemption appeals we have people we have
poverty appeals people can't pay the tax
um the exemption um people are you know
they're looking for ways for Relief um
we see quite a bit of of low and
moderate appeals people looking for um
you know a little bit of money back on
the education portion and yes I I can
get you actual statistics if that's what
you'd like I'm happy to provide that but
the numbers the last couple years um
after covid are are starting to rise
again um and we're just we we also have
a rise in reassessments
um there are less and less L appraisers
Statewide they're
retiring this position was vacant in the
last biennium we've had a challenge to
because the salary is not um not enough
to get people in the door people in
municipalities are actually they're
making more than we can offer so we're
competing with that we're competing with
um you know the private sector anyway
but now we're competing with
municipalities which That Never Was a
problem before
so we couldn't we can't even find an
appraiser and I wish the state had a
pool of people that we could all kind of
share cuz I know dot has some but we get
appeals from dot so that doesn't work um
Dr certainly hasn't you know I wish
there was a way to do that we've talked
about that before but um strictly
speaking um we have to do something
different with the position where we can
do a little bit of the appraisal work
and also get us some sta some some help
for for um what what my position does
because I have no backup um so yep okay
yeah that was going to be my next
question is is can you if if you get the
position back and can you actually find
someone and you mentioned reclassifying
that position I want if you could talk a
little bit about that as far as what you
want to do with
it okay yeah um we're going to look at
what duties without a professional
appraisal license um
perhaps those duties that could be done
by someone without a license or without
being certified by
that could still work um doing some
maybe going out to towns and collecting
some of the data because again we lost
the software to another budget cut so we
don't have um and that company real data
went out of business I believe anyway we
don't get any of that data so we have to
go collect it um so we could have some
of those duties be doing some of that
fine line of not performing appraisals
or anything like that but just
information collecting working with the
the towns and the assessors
and then on the other hand I need
someone that can be sort of the
financial backup part of my job is not
only office and Personnel Administration
but Financial in in um financial
management we we have to take all the
deposi of damages from do I'm sitting on
a bank account with over a million
dollars waiting for condomn E I've got
to distribute that money I've got to
account for that I need some help
financially with the duties yeah I we're
not attached to anyone so we have our
own database to manage which has to be
audited and there's there's all these
pieces of I'm wearing 12 hats which
other agencies have people to do those
jobs but in a small agency it's kind of
it's kind of centered on a few of us so
um part of the duties would be to be my
backup um because if if if something
happens to me there's no one there to do
the work that's the reality so it would
be kind of a mixed position and we we
had that on a different level years ago
I think in 2008 we had a program
assistant that did kind of that work but
we personnel and we've talked about this
it needs to be a higher level needs to
be somebody that can step into my shoes
if if I can't necessarily do that um and
and again our the two employees that we
have do radically different job duties
and they're they're I can't pull them
away from that either because again
there's only so much of us to handle the
work so hope that aners your question
yes it does and and I just want to let
you I know we talked about uh potential
hb2 and uh that's a great reminder for
for me to uh get it in front of uh
governor-elect aot and her team to uh to
put in the next budget if if if uh the
new governor decides to fund this
position it would actually be uh going
into hb1 and just be of your your
operating budget going forward that'd be
part of your efficiency budget so that's
how it would work thank
you could I just we get off that topic
if if the new governor does fund that
position we'd like the name of the
position to be changed because it
wouldn't be a review
appraiser that at least 60% of the work
if not more would be working with an on
on the duties that she has
so um whether it would require a
different um position number I would
assume it would but what we're looking
budget I I would just say that it would
it would be the continuation of the
existing position and the position would
be reclassed is how that would work so
the the budget item wouldn't actually um
fund a specific title per se unless you
eliminated the old position started a
new one and that would just take a long
time which nobody wants nobody wants it
to take a long time um I think what
might be helpful because it's not an
additional prioritized need currently in
your budget is if you would to write
something up just like a short one pager
probably less than one page um what
you're asking for how much it costs and
then a description of why and then I
think that's useful the the new
Governor's probably going to have in her
budget team we have a lot of requests
and it's useful to have that so that
they don't have to necessarily go back
and look at the transcript of this
meeting not that there'll be a
transcript um which makes it even
harder um so I would say that the other
thing is I wanted to ask um I know
you're sort of a vestage of the old Tax
Commission um back in the day um which
probably nobody remembers um in the room
except maybe Ken um and
um has there and so you have a board of
three people that hears that hears the
appeals has there there ever been any I
and I I suspect that's in statute has
there ever been any discussion about
doing more of a hearings office or
officer kind of a model or I guess we
now call them administrative law
judges there has been um and we've
talked about maybe a small claims but
the and it it was a board of four when
we when we merged the eminent domain
commission and the board of tax and land
appeals and in
2012 the legislature
put something in House Bill too where
they um took out one of the board member
positions so we are a three member
board because of the complexity of the
cases that we have now they're not your
mom and pop home you know assess for a
couple
hundred, we've got the commercial the
industrial the
contaminated there are so many that we
need to work in function as a board so
that we're our rulings are
consistent and that would be difficult
if it was if we work just as a single
board member hearing a case we did when
we had four members at one point because
we had so many cases and you know
Johnson Hall we were on the third floor
of Johnson Hall we created a second
hearing room and we had dual cases going
on two members in one room two members
in the other room and that worked quite
well for quite a long time but we had a
lot more staff which we don't have now
and quite honestly can I just and I'm
not trying to tell my own horn I just
Charlie knows how long I've been around
too long probably I'm not um we just
hire well the court we just had the law
changed so that the governor and Council
will now
um appoint a board member prior to that
it was the Supreme Court the last two
positions that needed to be filled was
one of our uh members who had her term
and she requested another term and the
way the new court was handling it was
to put something out on the web saying
we've got a position that's open and
we've got a board member already there
she wants a job but you know anybody
else that may be interested you can
apply the the court clerk was reporting
to me on all of this not one person
applied and then we had a member who
resigned or retired recently about a
year ago and they posted the position
and only one one person applied
and
luckily he started in January he's great
he's a young attorney he knows the law
he researches the law so we we Lo out
and we found someone but we need the
consistency of the board members to be
able to be fair to all the
taxpayers and the other issue is a lot
of people aren't applying because the
salary is still at the level DD which is
you know everybody not as high as it
might be everybody that comes before us
earns more money than we do yet we need
to know more than they
do well I I thank you people may not
know but Michelle is the currently the
longest serving state employee in
continuous service um and uh thank you
for your service well thank
you I will tell you my term is up in May
and I do plan on trying to get another
longer we appreciate your help um we
understand it's a it's a tough time but
you know it's a tough time for taxpayers
and that's who we wish to help out thank
now the judicial councel please like to
presentation there you go good afternoon
good
afternoon my name is Jay Bucky I am the
executive director of the judicial
Council the judicial Council exists as
both an agency and also as an advisory
committee made up of members from
representatives from all three branches
of government as well as lay
members the budget that is set forward
in the agency's budget book is based on
a proposal that that was reviewed and
voted on by the entirety of the judicial
Council as an agency the council has
several
responsibilities first to administer the
Indigent defense delivery system and
ensure its quality and cost
Effectiveness this includes paying for
services other than Council in indent
defense cases such as experts and
evaluations the judicial Council also
provides legal services to parents and
children in abuse neglect cases and in
cases involving the termination of
parental rights recent legislation has
expanded the right to counsel for
children in these
cases the judicial Council provides
legal services for Indigent proposed
Wards and guardianship proceedings as
well and provides for non-asa guardan
and liem services um in child abuse and
neglect cases when a casa is Casa gal is
not
available the judicial council is also
the mechanism by which the state funds
the casa program through a public
private partnership as well as provides
funding for New Hampshire legal
assistance Indigent defense is
specifically required in the New
Hampshire state
Constitution funding and overseeing
Indigent defense is by far the largest
and most important role of the judicial
Council as an
agency I would really like to focus this
presentation on the agency's most
pressing prioritized need in our budget
book and that is the New Hampshire
public
defender the New Hampshire public
defender operates on a contract model
with the state and handles most Indigent
defense cases in New Hampshire in 2023
that was 21,3
cases that's the bulk of all cases where
an Indigent person is facing
incarceration as a result of a criminal
charge because of the rules governing
conflicts of interest the New Hampshire
public defender cannot take all Indigent
defense cases in the state the cases
that nhpd cannot take are given to
contract
counsel and then to assign counsel if no
contract attorney is
available assigned counsel and contract
counsil are private attorneys who are
willing and qualified to take on
Indigent defense
cases as you can see from the handout I
prepared for today the contract cost for
the public defender incorporates not
just the services of its lawyers in
taking cases but also the Investigation
Services paralal Services it and
training that New Hampshire public
defender
uses for today I tried to prepare a
comparison of the cost of the nhp
contract for Indigent defense when
compared to the other viable alternative
which is a sign
Council as you can see from that
comparison using nhpd for these Services
is much more affordable and it's not
even close it's over $20 million more
affordable to use nhpd for these
services this is likely due to the
economies of scale that New Hampshire
public defender has as what is the
largest law firm in the state and it PD
has also developed internal efficiencies
such as in-house investigators dedicated
staff who close cases for attorneys
paralegals that operat in house
investments in it and
training it is simply much more
expensive to do what nhpd does through a
sign Council than it is to have nhpd do
it on a contract
model and unfortunately the public
defender is under
strain as you can see in the charts in
the handout the nature of cases has
changed
dramatically to give an
example a simple misdemeanor operating
after suspension charge essentially a
routine traffic crime used to involve
perhaps a single police report of a page
sometimes a paragraph even that same
case today could have hours of police
body camera Cruiser camera and
processing footage the data for that
particular case for an attorney to
review has grown exponentially and
that's why I've included the data from
public defender showing their storage
over
time and that's just for a simple
routine misdemeanor and there are
thousands of those a complex case such
as a YDC criminal case which the JD
which which the judicial Council funds
several of can involve hundreds of
thousands of pages of Discovery so much
discovery that requires specialized
Services just to organize index and
review that discovery and that doesn't
include time for experts and other
expenses involved um in preparing those
cases I also want to point out the
recent proliferation of specialty courts
including mental health courts drug
courts veterans courts all of which have
have had major benefits for the state
but all these courts constitute an
additional resource Demand on the public
defender representatives from the public
defender are expected to staff and be
present at these courts throughout the
state and they do that however this
takes
time process changes in the criminal
defense world have also impacted the
provision of indigent defense with the
end of felonies first there are now more
Courts for staff for attorneys to staff
at arraignments essentially we've gone
from having to staff 10 Superior Courts
which had arraignments at more or less
predictable times to over 30 circuit
courts which do not have the same level
of
predictability that takes more time for
the the public
defender further cases now take longer
essentially by Design especially felony
cases every felony case for the most
part starts off in District Court
instead of Superior Court starts off
with an arraignment which must be
staffed and then a probable cause
hearing which is an additional hearing
and then the case is bound over to
Superior Court where the case
essentially starts again this takes
additional
time these factors have led to case
loads remaining stubbornly high and
based on review the Accord to the
reports that I receive and monthly
reports every public defender office
currently has case loads above what the
contract goals
are to add to this the pay for public
defenders has not remained
competitive starting pay for public
defenders in New Hampshire lags behind
every single County Attorney office in
the state New Hampshire also has the
lowest public defender salary salaries
in New
England the combination of the low pay
and the High case loads has led to
Growing
attrition and I've included a chart in
the handout which shows this attrition
hasn't fact skyrocketed at the public
defender and it's led to a vicious cycle
lawyers leave the public defender based
on low pay and high case loads that
leaves more work for those who remain
the public defender who are then also um
generally considering leaving the trend
that I've shown in the in the graph
unfortunately is continuing into this
fiscal year my understand in is that 13
additional attorneys have given notice
since June 30th of this year for context
that's about 10% of the attorneys at
public defender just in the last four
months New Hampshire public defender
isn't just losing new lawyers but also
more experienced attorneys the attorneys
who can take on the serious felonies
that the state needs them to take on and
these attorneys who are also vital to
training and mentoring the next
generation of
attorneys case loads and attrition are
already having an impact in counties
around the state for example New
Hampshire public defender has had to
scale back representing clients that
some incarcerated arraignments in some
counties and scale back on representing
clients at War and pickups in some
counties courts now can and do directly
appoint Council to represent uh
defendants in these cases as defendants
have a constitutional right under both
the New Hampshire and a state
constitutions to council however when
courts directly assigned Council this is
more more expensive by far than having
public defenders do it but it puts
additional strain as well on the
contract and assigned Council system
which is already over
capacity because of all these factors
nhpd is the number one prioritize need
for the judicial Council the judicial
Council voted to recommend a substantial
increase in nhpd funding which is in my
schedule
D the prioritized need for nhpd was that
was voted on aimed to stabilize the
public defender by setting starting
salaries that are on par with County
attorney offices throughout the state as
well as adding additional attorneys to
make sure that case loads remain
reasonable and
sustainable the cost to increasing the
funding to nhbd would be far less than
having to fund the services that NBD
Council I should emphasize that because
the funding to the public defender is
made in contract form it needs to be up
allocated as part of the initial budget
in order for the program to plan and
recruit
effectively besides the public defender
there are other prioritized needs I
would like to touch on first the
contract Council program contract
Council are attorneys who take a fixed
number of cases at a fixed rate the
purpose of the contract program was to
provide representation to defendants at
a more economical rate than assign
counsil however the contract program has
dropped off precipitously with fewer
than half the attorneys who used to take
cases now taking
cases if contract if the contract
program is going to remain an option the
system must be revitalized a new
proposed contract with simplifies term
simplified terms and increased
compensation needs to be finalized
submitted and approved but this would
require additional funding which is part
needs assigned Council funding is also a
prioritized need
as noted in the handout at any one time
in New Hampshire 20 to 40 defendants are
incarcerated on criminal charges without
Council sometimes these defendants are
incarcerated for weeks while awaiting
Council recent statutory changes have
made it unlawful to provide legal
services to children on a fixed fee
basis in essence this has increased the
number of cases that now must be handled
by assign Council again which
contributes to the prioritized need
request for assign
Council there are currently not enough
attorneys willing and qualified to
provide services at the current contract
hour the assigned Council line also
includes attorneys who provide services
to children and parents and abuse to
neglect in termination of parental
rights cases as well as guardianship
cases the number of these attorneys has
shrunk dramatically especially in rural
areas where there are now legal deserts
which you may have heard of from other
presentations essentially areas where
there are two few few attorneys to meet
the needs of their
residents because of this shortage of
attorneys and the lack of attorneys
willing to take on these cases the
judicial Council recommended that the
Supreme Court raise the rates for
assigned Council again currently at $90
to
$125 the advisory committee on the rules
voted to recommend this change but this
potential change is still pending if
adopted this proposal would require
additional
appropriation which again is why it's
part of my prioritized needs package
not included on the handout but
nevertheless an important feature of the
budget is services
for a Services other than
Council expenditures for services other
than Council have been steadily
Rising as outlined in the hand out cases
last longer and involve much more
data correspondingly there's been an
increase in the use of experts in cases
translation services document management
and
evaluations evaluations are now much
more more common in criminal cases
across the board and in other cases as
well this includes evaluations for
mental health drug addiction and others
there's also been issues where due to
stabing shortages at the forensic
examiner certain competence evaluations
are now sought and paid for through
defense I'd like to also point out two
other agencies that judicial Council
supports and their budgetary needs first
Casa which stands for which is short for
guardian of excuse me court appointed
special
Advocates kasas are volunteers Who
currently are comp excuse me Costas are
volunteers who provide services in abuse
and neglect and tpr cases as part of my
role at the judicial Council have had
the opportunity to attend CA training
and also to observe Costas in
court I think it's important to
recognize that these are volunteers who
work extremely hard on what are very
difficult cases and their jeed to
cross-examination by trained lawyers
their training is excellent and the caes
that I've had opportunity to observe in
court are both professional and prepared
the state is incredibly fortunate to
have their use uh and to have volunteers
willing to work on these cases and their
work product based on my conversation
with judges who hear the cases is
incredibly important in determining the
outcomes the priori prioritized need for
the casa line is aimed at meeting their
costs for Casa which are expected to
increase again these costs dealing with
um the Staffing and other resources they
provide
volunteers I'd also like to touch on
Hampshire Legal
Assistance nhla New Hampshire legal
assistance provides a broad selection of
services on the Civil side to New
Hampshire residents most notably for
today I'd like to touch on their work in
domestic violence their work is both
Innovative and efficient I had the
opportunity to go to a court where nhla
had set up a domestic violence clinic
this Clinic was a model in providing
services when needed as needed to
domestic abuse victims anyone who's ever
spent time in a circuit court can see
the
people who really need help those people
are often searching for assistance and
assistance usually and they're usually
asking clerks for help and clerks really
aren't equipped to provide that kind of
help an nhla Domestic Violence Clinic is
a great example where they have lawyers
in the court who provide services to
someone who walks in whether they're off
the street or whether they've been
referred to by another source
it's an incredibly efficient use of
resources and the prioritized needs on
this line is aimed towards funding for
reopening a Nashville Office in a
populous area of the
state I'd like to conclude by talking
about our agency budget
request as you can see in the
handout one recommendation from the
recent audit of the judicial Council was
for the hiring of a finance manager this
position would help the agency with
financial oversight but could also help
with needed changes to payment
processing and other
processes the judicial Council has been
working steadily to increase efficiency
and costs when it comes to the
administration and funding of the
programs we support we have just today
sought and obtained Federal funding to
improve our database and payment system
we have worked with the courts and lean
office to streamline the pce payment
processing for certain routine vendors
and to save time for judges and Court
staff we will be proposing changes to
rules in hb2 rules and statutes to
enable the judicial Council to negotiate
better and more uniform rates for
services which could save the state a
great deal of money when it comes to
Services other than Council as an agency
we remain committed to finding
efficiencies wherever
possible just like to conclude by
mentioning that the judicial Council
provides services to Citizens every day
in every Court in the state having had a
chance to review what the agency does as
as part of my introduction to this job I
can I'm very proud of the services we
provide however I do want to convey that
the system as it currently stands is
under tremendous strain and cracks are
showing when adjusted for inflation nhpd
funding has actually gone down since
2014 I get calls every week and
sometimes every day from defendants who
are in jail asking why they don't have a
lawyer I hear from courts and
prosecutors asking why a defendant
doesn't have a
lawyer I see experienced lawyers leaving
New Hampshire public defender with no
easy replace
our budget is aimed at addressing these
issues and I thank you for for
considering
it thank you uh just looking over the
numbers your your your budget in in 2023
was was approximately 31 million and
that was increased to 37 million in
fiscal year 25 for about a 20% increase
is that
correct correct okay and and with the
with the changes you're proposing
proposing now uh including the the
additional prioritized needs that would
bring it up to just just over 55 million
for an additional 48.6% increase I'd
have to double check because some of
those items included there is federal
funding that's dropped off as well but I
believe that is correct 55 million yes
yeah okay uh my and that's just a
historic budget um statistics which I
love but uh my my my question really is
as far as the public defenders
uh office goes in the need for the
public
defenders uh obviously the public
defenders are there for people cannot
otherwise afford to
pay uh currently New Hampshire's economy
is in excellent shape we have
historically low unemployment 2.5% we're
the lowest uh we have the lowest uh
poverty rate in the country currently if
that were to change if we were to hit a
recession and we were to see
unemployment go up or like even if we
still are number one as far as uh our
poverty rate goes uh but that were to
increase as well could we
expect the need for the public defender
office to increase even greater under
those
circumstances yes uh and just one point
of context the determination of who who
qualifies for a public defender in the
first instance is made by the courts by
under administrative rules from Das but
yes I think absolutely I think those
determinations on incy would would
likely increase
thank
you hi good to see you I'm seeing a lot
of you today
um couple of questions one is um so the
way we budget judicial council is
remarkably fake in New Hampshire isn't
it um there's a footnote in the budget
that says we're going to give you X
number of dollars which is sort of made
up and um and you can go back to fiscal
and get as much as you need cuz we if I
understand this right and stop me if I
say something wrong if I understand this
right there's a sixth amendment
requirement to provide etc etc um which
were currently not according to the LBA
audit which we're failing on um not
failing in danger of I forget their
language it ain't going well um but so
we'll we'll budget 31 million and then
everyone Winks to themselves and goes we
know we're going to spend 40 and they'll
just go to fiscal and get it what what
have you spent the last actually spent
numbers on on public defender on let's
say public defender let's start there
well we spent exactly what's been for
the public defender I think the there's
been small lapses but we spent
essentially what's ever been allocated
with small and the extra is usually a
signed councel or contract
councel we've spent I know since I was
here last for the last budget cycle we
spent far over what was allocated to
assign Council because of that cork
which you just mentioned the you know
the allocation was lower than I think
what was expected and we predictively
came to to to come back to the fiscal
committee to ask for more so do I
understand your request correctly that
um if I understand this right based on
2023 case
loads it would be $47 million at current
rates and if we rais the rates it would
be more than that I'm looking at page
two of your presentation if you the of
that is to show what would it cost
correct if you just did it as a sign
Council if you got rid of the public
defender and did it as a sign Council it
would cost 47 million so every public
defender case worth sort of saving money
is that fair to say in fact if there's
one thing I could convey you're saving a
lot of money with a public defender case
um if you look at the numbers and
there's just one takeaway I can put
forward the public defender because of
needs to be funded upfront because of
the way it operates it's a you know it
has a two-year cycle and it needs to
hire people and do all that and it's an
organization if it doesn't get that uo
funding um it can't obviously plan and
the if it if instead of we're paying
things through assign counsel we're
paying essentially twice as much per
case even though so it might look like
The Upfront cost is lower but the
overall cost is much much higher and
that's what I'm trying to demonstrate so
if you look at that handout basically if
you took if you took the cases that the
public defender does and you were to pay
all those cases simply as ass signed
Council which just to be clear you
couldn't do because there not but just
just for out of curiosity you say okay
we're just doing assign Council all the
way um it would be about double the cost
and that I think is due to the
efficiencies involved in just simply
having one administrative unit you know
which is the public defender and the way
they handle things
um when I look at the numbers for
assigned Council those numbers are
wildly unpredictable and they go up a
lot um and they depend simply and they
can go up a lot based on big cases as
well I mean frankly if you're talking
pure economics the real savings in a
public defender office is on those
bigger cases because one big case a YDC
criminal defense case for example can be
six figures and that's just onest that's
for lawyer costs and add on top of that
um expert costs as well so
um if there's one big takeaway assigned
council is much more expensive and
that's been known for quite some time
and that's why under statute it's sort
of supposed to be the last resort but
because the contract system has you know
basically withered to a great degree ass
Council has really taken off and those
costs have grown my big concern right
now is if the public defender isn't
funded adequately those costs are going
to just explode even more and that's
just leaving aside the Constitutional
issue which is there aren't enough
lawyers and that the issue of people in
jail um without lawyers is going to go
up as well how long can you keep
somebody in jail without giving them a
lawyer uh that is a question that Oregon
says
Oregon says seven days um different
courts have that's a federal that's a
federal decision in Oregon um do we
exceed s days periodically yes
routinely
yes and is the concern that at some
point a court will look at that and um
be disappointed in
US yes okay probably more than
disappointed in US
the public defender if I understand the
public defender right I don't how big is
the public defender's office ballpark
attorney wise on 120 to 124 excuse me
122 I think currently it's 134 I have
the the training person here I give you
the exact number but somewhere between
120 and 140 and and the way New
Hampshire does it is is it is a it is a
nonprofit corporation whose entire
income is derived from one bi anal Grant
from the state is that correct
essentially yes with some small other
but for the most part yes um it wouldn't
be efficient to make it a department of
state
government we probably have to pay
more I don't have data on that point I
simp going on what what we look at right
now I haven't run that analysis I only
look at sort of the statutory options I
have currently which really are
nonprofit and um assign counsil but you
don't think that's an inefficient
Arrangement that with the one we have
today or or does
it I would say that it's much more
efficient than assigned counsel much
more efficient than contract counsel
whether it be more efficient to have it
as a state agency or not that's not a
calculation I've done yeah I'm guessing
probably not but that's my guess can you
talk a little bit about Casa yes if we
have somebody who's in need of a casa
person Kasa is a wonderful organization
that does great work for the well for
everybody but um if Casa doesn't have
somebody
what happens then that is an excellent
question which I should have included in
my report essentially what happens is if
Casa cannot staff someone the case then
goes to a a non-cost of G and they are
essentially compensated as a signed
Council and whereas Casa
is not compensated at that rate correct
so we pay Casa you know we give them a
fixed amount of money for training and
for Staffing um again not Staffing but
Staffing that they support attorneys um
whereas U yeah we don't pay we don't pay
their their volunteers do not send us a
bill whereas the non-asa Gils do they
send us a bill just like an attorney
would essentially so we're sort of
saving money hand over fist um with Casa
is that a fair statement that's uh
you any other questions thank you very
Labor afternoon
commissioner good afternoon um for the
record I am Ken marfield commissioner of
the Department of Labor I'm joined by
Deputy Commissioner Danielle Albert and
to her left is our director of
administration Amy
O'Hara for me for prepared remarks I
only get to do this every couple of
years or so
so the uh the department consists of
three divisions Administration which
includes department-wide efforts like
Legal Services finance and Human
Resources uh the Inspection Division and
the Workers Compensation Division the
inspection division is responsible for
administering and enforcing the
protective legislation law the citizens
job protection statute the
whistleblowers protection statute the
youth employment law the minimum wage
law the New Hampshire warrant act uh
rather famously the boiler and pressure
vessel law and the elevator and
accessibility lift law uh also safety
and health laws uh and along with these
statutes the division also enforces
administrative rules uh dealing with the
very same subject matter in a typical
year the Inspection Division will
recover anywhere from a half million to
a million dollars in wages for New
Hampshire employees uh completes uh
roughly a thousand uh labor inspections
of various
types uh completes roughly 10,000 boiler
or pressure vessel inspections and uh
over 5,000 elevator inspections the
division is also proactive training
employers every year on employment law
to assist them with their legal
compliance uh since the pandemic the
division has made excellent use of
webinar technology
to provide these trainings in a virtual
environment division leadership and
Department leadership also uh provide
trainings live trainings to interested
industry groups uh as well throughout
the year the work in worker Compensation
Division on the other hand was created
in
1947 and has the responsibility for
administrating the state's worker
compensation law originally enacted in
1911 it requires uh employers to m
maintain insurance coverage to provide
no fault compensation for employees in
case of accidental injury death or
occupational disease arising out of the
course of
employment among other duties excuse me
the uh worker Compensation Division
collects first reports of injury from
employers and insurance carriers in New
Hampshire regarding the roughly 40,000
or so workplace injuries that occur each
year it schedules over uh, 1500 for
normal hearings per year and manages
revolving trust fund Collections and
payments uh that can be as high as 20
million doar a year and as as you can
see that is almost doubled the entire
operating budget of of the department uh
while the Department's total
Appropriations are funded 100% by agency
income that revenue is actually derived
through two distinct sources first the
administration fund and secondly the
restricted fund the administration fund
is described in RSA 281a col 59 and it
comes from a prata assessment of the
Department's approved annual budget for
worker compensation activities that is
then levied on the workers compensation
insurance carriers and self-insured
entities in New Hampshire this
assessment actually uh for the the first
year of the new bium uh in our request
represents 87% of our total
Department the restricted fund on the
other hand is described in RSA
273 colon 1B and it comes from the sum
of all other fees fines licenses uh
civil penalties uh certificates uh all
the other revenue of the department that
is not associated with worker
compensation uh and the
balance remaining after our expens enses
in the restricted fund the balance is
transferred to the general fund at the
end of each fiscal year and uh I can
report that the last four years have
been the best four years in terms of
that general fund
transfer uh exceeding in fact last state
fiscal year exceeding $2
million uh the governor's office
provided us an overall efficiency Target
of 12 Mill just over $12 million in year
one the adjusted year 2 Target
was 12.4 Million after allowances for
position cost
Corrections uh the labor department has
met both targets with our efficiency
budget request and uh while we have
requested no new positions for fiscal 26
or 27 uh leaving us with 87 full-time
authorized positions as supported in the
prior bium uh we did uh in order to meet
efficiency targets and maintain some uh
operational uh efficiency we did uh
freeze the funding for three positions
in in the next
bium uh notable changes in our
efficiency request for for the coming
bium include a slight increase in class
17 uh special payments which we use to
fund uh retirement payouts or uh when
someone terminates State service they're
they're entitled also to a payout so
allows us to do that without impacting
our salary lines um I did a calculation
yesterday I think if if everyone were to
leave and everyone eligible to retire it
would be on the order of
$300,000 and um so we've asked for
significantly less than that because we
don't think that that'll happen
uh um also uh let's see we have uh
significant reductions in our transfers
to doit and to General services so thank
you Charlie thank you Dennis uh we have
an increase in equipment in year one for
the purchase of a new truck to
facilitate the transport of elevator
testing weights uh I have learned in uh
recent days that we are transporting
something like 1,400 pound of testing
weights for elevators in um little
sedans
sometimes subcompacts and it's tearing
those Vehicles apart so in order to save
those Vehicles we'd like to we'd like to
purchase a truck that's better capable
of doing that um we also had a we've had
a significant increase in indirect costs
uh to cover the large increases that
we've experienced in Statewide cost
allocation plan costs virtually double
what what we budgeted uh La uh year
before last so
um yes and uh We've significantly
reduced the budget for part-time
temporary staffing but increased the
budget for our administratively attached
boards uh a couple of the boards that
are attached the labor department
receive per DM costs and travel costs uh
for their service and um my concern
there is not that uh U you know the
current trend is less than budget uh how
however if I don't have funding in those
lines the the result could be that uh
citizens are waiting for services that
they they should be getting timely by
law um so I like to protect a little bit
in that class line uh We've also asked
for uh an increase in year one for our
class uh 103 operational
contracts um again we haven't made great
use of this but but I envision
circumstances where we would like to
fund um projects within the Spalding
building including uh redesign of of
work areas there are some other needs
that that we have in the building I
found commissioner Arling house is a lot
more receptive to my requests when I pay
for them so um that's what I have in
mind
yes uh we we also do have uh some small
prior well relatively small prioritize
needs uh amounting in uh to less than
$330,000 throughout the bium uh those
were both requested by doit and admin
Services they're they're not um
specifically our requests and that
questions questions I have lots of
questions oh good I didn't know what I
was going to do with my afternoon
Charlie no it's very important
um uh you're administrative lapse which
I think was 2.8 million last year so
your modest was almost three
um I'm asking this because it's a there
are a bunch of other agencies where when
they have these these fees etc etc they
keep rolling them over and over and over
again and they they don't lapse anything
they just roll which obviously if you're
doing a Statewide budget is less than
ideal although it's great for that
agency um you keep it do you have like a
do you have an amount you keep in in
Balance like the first 100 Grand you
keep and the rest you
lapse or do you just lapse It
All We lapse everything from the
restricted fund that's what I mean but
but I would I would call your attention
to the administration fund which again
is like 87% of our request that rolls
into the next year and depresses the
assessment for the workers comp
insurance carriers and that's the that's
the thing where we do we're essentially
Dunning carriers for the cost of that
but for the rest of it you're lapsing a
good amount of money yep um and that's
from various fees and whatnot that's
every other type of Revenue that we
collect other than the billing for the
insurance carriers for workers comp
every other fee that we collect at the
end of the year whatever we haven't
needed to support our expenses is
transfer and you you laps the whole
thing yeah yeah okay I'm not critical of
that I just in the back of my mind I
think it might work other places too um
excellent I'm happy to assist with that
um thank you for that secondly I wanted
to talk about in in an earlier point in
the day I was talking to somebody about
um things like hearing officers you do a
lot of Fairly complicated cases I think
with hearing officers I I would say so
I've been told differently by other
hearings officers but but uh uh yes uh a
number like the statutes that I cited
you know any number of those would would
come up in a hearing setting and worker
compensation being the bulk of the
hearings that we conduct and which are
often fairly complicated I would argue
so yes okay and it's one I think we
called them administrative law judges
now indeed um and it's typically how
it's there's one judge both parties
present and that he or she then
adjudicates and writes an opinion
renders a decision within 30 days and
within 30 days and you stick to that
pretty good within 30 days yeah very
very well in fact during the pandemic I
don't think we had a single late here we
held hearings on time and we produce
decisions on time it's a very it's a
very rare circumstance that we're late
because the law says we can't be so okay
and as the star of elevators everywhere
um there are some states in which the
the commissioner of Labor when he
inspects an elevator doesn't just have
his signature on it but also his picture
I've been told have you considered that
option I have not seriously considered
you thank you very much thank
you like to invite up now the public
good afternoon good afternoon uh my name
is Doug ingersol I'm the executive
director of the Public Employee Labor
Relations Board I've been with the board
since 2006 I work with two other
full-time employees and the board itself
uh consists of nine authorized positions
we currently have seven board members
and two
vacancies um I'd like to divide my very
brief comments today into two parts one
uh a few words about operations and then
two a few comments about our budget
requests uh in terms of operations I
have uh
circulated an information sheet which
hits uh the major activity areas we are
responsible for administering the
state's public sector collective
bargaining law which affects employers
at the state county City Municipal
School District levels employers and
employees who work in those
areas we currently have upwards of 600
bargaining units in place which
corresponds to uh a similar number of
contracts that are negotiated between
those parties uh usually every one to
three years depending on their contract
term uh and then under our statute um if
there are potential conflicts and Labor
Relations uh covered by the statute
parties are free to file complaints with
us and we have a hearing process uh we
also look at bargaining unit composition
not only when new units are formed but
to make adjustments by adding or using
positions we typically use a hearing
officer for that
process uh we also have a panel of
neutrals who work as arbitrators
FactFinder uh and mediators in contract
negotiations um
I listened to to Michelle lebrun's
presentation her and and the comment
about her status as the longest serving
state employee uh her mother uh Evelyn I
think was the first uh executive
director of our board and served from
the 1970s through
1990 um and I think left quite a
legacy um in terms of the uh budget
request itself uh it's pretty consistent
with what we've asked for in Prior years
uh there is a defunding of one of our
positions to meet the Target that we
were given by the governor's
office um that position is currently
vacant anyway but certainly spoils any
plans I may have had to uh bring a
person on board uh in the near-
term
um I have included a request to increase
a board per DM to $250
and we'll follow the hb2 protocol uh
discussed in a recent email from budget
director Gary for that but the original
board per DM in 1976 was $25 it was
doubled to $50 in 1985 and it's stayed
there ever since
so the net to a board member for a full
day's work is
$37 obviously those pdms are not meant
um as a a living wage or full
compensation to board members most of
them are otherwise employed
professionals um but they do deal with
some difficult cases and some difficult
issues and they work hard to to make
fair and correct decisions and I think
it would be
appropriate uh to bring the to raise the
per DM up to the $250 level which I
think is still fairly modest um and it's
the first time I've submitted such a
request I I don't know if there was ever
a request prior to 2006 to address that
amount
um class uh 27 doit the only real change
there is we have implemented legal files
case management software and so going
forward there's going to be an on
ongoing carrying cost associated with
licenses which is around 6,00 000 a year
um I think the money necessary to
implement and get training configuration
completed is covered in our fiscal year
2425 budget and that whole process is
going well uh and we have been using
that new software since
July uh Board of tax and land appeals
apparently has been using it for over 20
years and I believe there are another
other small boards and departments that
may also be uh working on cont tracks
with legal
files um when we re eliminated funding
for the position that I mentioned it
created the opportunity to include some
funds uh for equipment um to to address
our hearing room tables and chairs I had
included funding for that in fiscal year
24 hadn't done research ahead of time
and found out the funds that I had
available were wellfully inadequate to
address our our equipment needs so uh
there is funding in there uh for both
fiscal years and I think you will see in
authorized fiscal year 25 that that
number was
Zero um normally we don't we don't have
much demand for for equipment but those
are the highlights I don't really have
any
other specific things I want to bring to
your attention happy to answer any
questions Ju Just an update if you you
could provide one I know as you
mentioned in your report that you just
switched over on July 1 to a to a new
case management system how's that how is
that going and what your experience with
that yeah
I I don't think that we've obtained full
proficiency but we put a lot of work in
in the spring uh working with the vendor
on training and
configuration and because we were
configuring A system that we didn't
understand it wasn't like going to buy
another a new car that now had AC we
were buying something we didn't
understand how it was going to work
except based on anecdotal information
and a a brief video uh demonstration but
I'm very happy with it I think it
actually has increased our efficiencies
in terms of managing information that
comes in tracking our docket keeping
track of the small things that have to
happen every day to keep the docket
moving and make sure that things aren't
missed uh so I I would support anybody
who was running an operation similar to
ours uh using it I think it has to be it
seems to be geared toward a legal based
uh system uh and if it's more of a
business administration type environment
may not be
appropriate thank
you I would note um I don't think
there's been a comprehensive study of
part-time adjudicative boards in the
state but um compensation for them seems
to be all over the map and um I would
say you're among the
lowest um not quite the lowest I think
the board of claims who gets like 45
bucks a quarter whether they have cases
or not which is the equivalent of a part
of a volunteer job if you ask me um is
probably the lowest and the Personnel
appeals board might be the highest
because I think they also get a weekly
stipend but um I suspect that as maybe
as a result of your request there might
be some interest in looking at that uh
looking at some Equity Statewide and and
how that I I do understand um am I right
about your board that um board members
don't write the decisions you do that's
correct and that's probably a good
system because you kind of know what
you're doing let's assume you know what
you're doing it seems to work pretty
well okay and uh but if anyone's
listening who has an interest in it I
think it's something where we might want
to look at some sort of equity Statewide
because even the part-time boards
there's no equity as opposed to the
couple of full-time boards
where yeah I I mean any anybody serving
on any board in the state is making a
commitment um but there are definitely I
think occasions when the work required
and the stress involved is maybe higher
than was
anticipated I've been pretty fortunate
fortunate with my board I feel like
they've always maintained their
composure and had a good attitude about
getting the work done and I I don't
think the $50 per DM is going to be a
breaking point but I think an adjustment
is probably
overdue and I just want to clarify I'm
right about this I think that you're the
Public Employee Labor Relations Board
for the entire State of New Hampshire
school boards cities towns counties
you thank you very much thank you very
much we will now be
uh in in recess for about 5 minutes
2:45
e
everyone to take their seats so we can
reconvene
and I'd like to invite up now the
university
system that's where we are and
Chancellor
preventure good afternoon um panel for
the Governor's budget hearing um for the
record my name is Katherine prenter I
serve as the chancellor of our state's
University system i' like to
congratulate uh governor-elect Kelly aot
and Senator gray on um their elections
last week so um I'd really like to this
to be more interactive so I don't have a
lot of slides um but um would like to
provide you some information about
what's going on at the University system
and the request that you'll find in the
um the governor's phase of the budget so
there are a few slides I think I have
maybe nine slides in front of you and on
slide two this is a screenshot of page
3,879 in your budget book The University
system is one very large appropriation
line generally funded in the state
budget and um as directed by the
governor's office and the department of
administra administrative Services the
request for fiscal years 26 and 27 7 is
91.2 million it represents um a 4%
reduction over the current level of our
block grant an 8% reduction if you
include that onetime funding that the
university system was appropriated in
fiscal
24 um this is not what we would have um
requested out of the gate as a
recovering auditor from my many years at
the LBA audit division I generally
follow the rules and we requested what
um the direction was provided uh by the
governor's office and administrative
Services we would like to see that
appropriation flat at $95 million in
each of the next two fiscal years to
continue the work that is happening at
the University system I'll get into that
in a minute we um very much rely on the
state support appreciate the levels of
State support that benefit our New
Hampshire students and families and the
programs that are um mandated by
Statute in order to make up this
reduction in state support if we were
going to make that up in in state with
instate tuition that would be about a 6%
increase in instate tuition which we we
cannot do the the market would not bear
that type of tuition increase and we
would not increase tuition at those
amounts to to um make up that
reduction on on slide three want to just
mention what the state investment is
used
for
we allocate almost the entirety of the
state investment toward buying down
instate tuition instate tuition runs
about half of what out of state tuition
runs because of increased State
investment
over the past half dozen years we've
been able to keep tuition flat actually
the net tuition paid by our New
Hampshire students has dropped by 6.7%
over the last 5 years because financial
aid has increased and um tuition has
stayed flat and I'm going to show you in
a minute that that has finally paid off
in the fall of
24 the um the other portion of the the
state investment is allocated to provide
partial um funding for statutory
mandated programs so Cooperative
Extension um agricultural experiment
station and the list you'll find on page
three there are other state mandated
programs that aren't included here that
we fund out of our budget the National
Guard tuition waivers for example those
were about $3 million just shy of $3
million last year as well as um tuition
waivers for Foster children so those are
other mandated programs that we need to
cover out of the
budget over those these past six years
the state investment has increased 7.3%
which is Meaningful right from the 85 A5
million to the 95 million um and you'll
see in a minute our enrollment is
declining I'm not going to say our
enrollment is not declining because it
it is so if you will flip
to slide four I do want to we we
are partnering closely with the Bia
community college system employers
around the state I'm going to get into a
little more detail in a moment about
that but one of the policy priorities of
the Bia for 24 is to explore ways that
we can increase support for public
higher education to keep more New
Hampshire students here and in the fall
of 24 for the first time since
2013 the university system New Hampshire
the first time class in of New Hampshire
students increased
2.8% which in this competitive
environment I believe is partially
because of the state investment that has
been made and we've been able to keep
tuition low so that is in my mind a good
thing for our students our families our
employers at the same time our
surrounding states are really doubling
down on investment because all of New
England is experiencing this this
demographic Challenge and all states are
trying to keep their students or frankly
take our students um to bolster their
future Workforce and economy and I'll
talk about a little bit more about that
in a minute so Slide Five graphic where
you see the New
Hampshire resident student increasing in
the fall of 2004 now again I don't want
this slide to imply that enrollment grew
it did not our enrollment continues to
decline because of demographic pressures
we expect it will continue to decline
and we're taking action I'll again get
into a little more um excuse me detail
about
that my my worry with this demographic
and the market competition for young
talent in New
England certainly is for the University
system but more importantly what does it
look like as our population ages for the
future Workforce future economy when the
the population of young Talent is
shrinking and H how do we continue to
compete and um be an attractive
affordable quality opportunity for
students in New Hampshire and in in the
region oh my next slide on slide six is
just more good news that the
demographics in New England are are
projected to continue to decline so the
we expect that if we can hold enrollment
flat that would be a win es again
especially in New
England and the university system is not
waiting for the next shoe to drop we are
not expecting the state to bail us out
of of this challenge that we know is
it's here and coming we are taking
significant action
and will plan to it will continue to
take bold action because we have to
change just about everything everything
about the way we're delivering Services
the size of our footprint all of
that so on slide seven I just have a few
examples of what we've done over the
past few years so while inflation has
grown 20% over those um over the past
three years our expenses have increased
3% how have we done some of that our um
faculty and staff headcount has reduced
we've reduced employer contributions to
our we don't belong to the retirement
system because we're not a state agency
but we have a it's a 403b it's like a
401k we've reduced our employer
contributions match we've reduced our
medical plans and increased our premiums
we've um we no longer provide employer
cont contributions toward vision and
dental we are demolishing buildings we
are selling buildings we are exiting
leases this is all part of we know we
have to reduce the cost structure and we
are taking action to do so we've also
invested in new technology we go live
with workday for HR and Finance in about
necessary the
um the next slides are really examples
about the competition that we're facing
around in the region slide
eight you may have seen Billboards that
UMaine has on the highways come to
UMaine for the same price that you pay
in state tuition Sunni is doing the same
thing um the Commonwealth of
Massachusetts has just come out with a
commonwealth
commitment again just increasing the
competition across the region
excuse me on slide
nine we are fully
embedded I will
say we are not the isolated
bureaucratic Ivory Tower that some may
have in their minds from many many years
ago we are fully embedded with thousands
of employers across the state with the
citizenry and communities through
Cooperative Extension the Partnerships
with the Community College Chancellor
Rubenstein and I are spending a lot of
quality time together we are embedded
Enterprise beholden to ourselves and
there are just some examples on the
slide and I have lots more um I firmly
believe that the university all of
public higher ed is a critical part of
the state's future um we are the
university system was the inaugural
higher ed member of New Hampshire Life
Sciences if you're familiar with that
newest Association we're just on a call
last week with Bea on the advanced
manufacturing
strategy internship programs with our
institutions is where it's at if we
non-resident students are twice as
likely to stay and work here if they're
in an internship program so partnering
with employers again thousands of
employers across the state to get our
students into internships and I
mentioned the Partnerships with the
community college system we've developed
a 100 Pathways between the community
college system the university system we
now have a direct admission program we
are collaborating on multiple
administrative fronts um actually the
university system office is moving to
the nhti campus in 2025 really trying to
um leverage scale wherever possible to
benefit students in the citizenry
through public um higher
ed and then on on slide 10 I just want
to close with some Innovation that's
happening at our institutions um you may
have recently read that Plymouth State
applied through um our New England
accreditors to deliver a three-year
bachelor's
degrees um in
five areas you'll see those on the first
bullet of the slide again thinking about
meeting our students where they are
delivering what students need um Keen
State this is interesting Senator gray
and I just have we had a board meeting
over at Keen State a couple weeks ago
and Senator gray and I sat at a table
with some Executives from um Diamond
turning I'm going to get the terminology
wrong Advanced
manufacturing companies over in the
madok region there are over half a dozen
of them and they're the global
leader in providing this diamond turning
Advanced manufacturing Precision
manufacturing and Keen state
is the only four-year college that has
been selected to partner with the
American Center for Optics manufacturing
and through some outside funding Keane
is completing a diamond turning Optics
lab again to collaborate with that
industry over in the madok region that's
employing over a thousand people it's
it's quite
remarkable um UNH research for an
institution its size it's a it's a
powerhouse it's
it's um it's surprising the other thing
about unh
the goal is to provide the undergrad
student opportunity to work on that
research not just let have the
researchers off um on their own it's
it's it's quite unique and then I'm I'm
not sure if you're aware of the John
olssen Advanced manufacturing center at
UNH um they provide learning
opportunities they have a remarkable
equipment High School community college
students small startups all all come
together in that Advanced manufacturing
center over in Durham and it's it's
UNH I'm going to close with that to give
you plenty of time to ask me questions
um I I will just say that the university
system is a remarkable resource to all
the citizens of the state and
um I
I I do not envy the position you are in
I was state treasur
2011 and that was a very very difficult
budget period And
I so I can identify and I I
um it's very difficult decisions but I
believe that public highed needs to be
part of where we're heading in the
future with Workforce Employers in the
economy so I appreciate your time and
happy to answer any
questions thank you very much Chancellor
uh my question revolves around tuition
and I was wondering if you could uh talk
about what you've been what historically
what you've done with tuition both in
state and out of state and maybe your
projections for the future for the next
few years as far as where that where
that's going so we have held tuition
flat for instate students for the past
six years this is the sixth year and
we've done that well you can see on
Slide
three we've done that because the state
um continued to
invest additional dollars each year um
understanding the okay wait I didn't
answerer the next part of your question
sorry for non-resident students we have
consistently raised tuition about 2 and
a half% per year so I'm I'm rounding but
out of state tuition is about double
what instate tuition is sticker price
not discounted with financial aid um and
again because the State dollars buy that
tuition down for our instate
students for next fiscal year for the
next academic
year starting in the fall of
25 our board just voted two weeks ago to
increase in state tuition by 2 and a
half%
up to oh yes I'm sorry yes Senator
absolutely Senator gray thank you for
that that um that point the motion is
always up to a maximum of 2 and a half%
so depending on what happens depending
on all kinds of things
competition we can go lower than that
but the board sets a cap on the increase
in
pricing as you you've consistently
raised by by the 2 and a half% for out
ofate tuition and kept instate tuition
flat have you notied the ratio of
students between out of state and
instate changed significantly over that
time period meaning are out of state
tuition students dropping off at a
five enrollment that's that's a tricky
question um
I will say the percentage has been
fairly consistent until this
fall when resident students went up and
non-resident students went
down um and that could be for many
reasons I I um it could be because other
states are investing heavily to keep
their students
there it it probably is partly because
we've te kept tuition flat for so long
we're not we're sorry we're no longer
the low the highest instate tuition in
New England Vermont is now you know we
used to be able we used to that used to
be oh we're the highest in state it's
still high I don't want to minimize that
we still have high in state tuition but
we're not the highest
anymore um and it could partially be
because of the fafs of
fiasco so there are multiple things that
could have caused this Divergence in
this chart um
but I I think it's a uh I think it's a
number of
factors I just wonder if you could
finally if you could just touch on that
in the financial aid and the and the I
would use the word fiasco that that
schools across this nation went through
uh this past summer and and and fall and
the impact they might have had on the
University system so um it we think it
definitely had an impact on the
University system Frank we think all of
higher red because students we have a
high percentage of students who are
considered first generation students you
might um actually the new president of
unh just had an op-ed in the union
leader a week or so ago about first
generation students who may not have the
supports at home to to navigate the
complicated Journey right of applying to
college and financial aid and the FAFSA
and all of that
well the FAFSA was not available when it
should have
been um the depart US Department of Ed
did not release the
new simplified FAFSA timely and then
what happened was schools didn't have
the data to prepare financial aid
packaging for
students so students didn't have the
information they needed to make a
decision and we know that many students
and families gave up actually granted
I don't know if you're familiar with
that nonprofit organization Christiana
Thorton is the executive director they
have been pounding the pavement all over
the state at fairs and concerts and
schools trying to get the word out that
there's help for students that need that
help um but we we do also think that
impact hi hi commissioner how are you
I'm great how are you uh better than
average um the average is pretty low
today so that's not really that great um
I have a couple of questions I wanted to
ask you about um you talked about
reducing staff and faculty and various
costs and whatnot um how so I friend of
mine who unfortunately died recently um
in his 80s but he taught at UNH for
about 40 years and he said to me once
the biggest difference between when he
started and I'm going to guess it was
the
60s um and today is that when he started
the Dean's office was a dean and a
secretary and that uh this about five or
six years ago he said and now it's like
104 people and I don't know what the
hell any of them do and uh his word's
not mine and uh there's a there's a
sense in some places that
occasionally in some academic
institutions probably less so in New
Hampshire there's a fewer people who are
do doing the the teaching bit and a lot
more people who are doing less of the
teaching piece do you have a sense of
that ratio and whether it's getting
better worse or
indifferent uh thank you for the
question commissioner I don't have a
sense of the ratio I can get that
information for you I will make an
educated guess that certainly you said
40 years that over a 40-year time
frame um the ratio of administration to
to faculty has has increased I'll give
you a couple reasons for that the
regulatory framework that highered now
finds itself
in um requires compliance at
Administration that maybe it did not
require 40 years ago um the the um
student Behavioral Health and student
needs and
supports um I believe are greater than
they were decades ago um so there there
are some reasons where why that ratio
could have changed over the decades um I
can follow up get some information on
that I'm more wondering L because the
60s was the 60s and I I was only alive
for half of them and um the but do you
think we're sort of crossing a line
where sort of we peaked on
administrative size and maybe are
dipping a bit because I'm sure it's
worse than 63 but how about 23 I do
commissioner and and frankly we're we're
not g to have a choice it's not it's not
going to be a choice anymore you see the
trends when Revenue stays flat and costs
increase the math doesn't work so um we
must reduce the cost structure and and
that's why we're looking at all
different ways to do that not just
employee comp right we have a footprint
we need to shrink if we have fewer
students so there there's a lot of work
at
had well good um I think uh I was happy
when they picked you as Chancellor um
because I I think I said to you it's
about time but um I think you're suited
to that work um instate versus out of
state I I I really enjoy the graph on
page five um it's like it was designed
to answer a question I had um but uh
it's different probably at Keen Plymouth
and UNH they're three different ratios
are we at the point now where UNH is
actually more out of state in
streate um I think we're about
5050 commissioner I wouldn't testify to
this in court as I'm sitting right here
right now that's good I don't think it
might be like 53 to 40 I mean it's
pretty close to
5050 um it it might be a little higher
on on the non-resident I would make a
point though that um non-resident
students are not a bad thing
um we're the young we're the largest in
migrator of young talent in the state
and we have institutions that are larger
than than our student population would
support and those non-resident students
bring economic activity to the state
they stay and work here their families
come here um I understand that the the
and believe that the state investment
should benefit our new Hampshire
students but non-resident students bring
benefit to to our state in my opinion is
it reasonable to say that to at least to
a small extent the out ofers are
subsidizing instate
tuition they are okay not not by a wide
margin but they are because if we look
at the state investment plus the net
tuition we receive from our New
Hampshire students it's slightly less
than the net tuition we receive from our
out of state students so there is some
subsidy would you know ballpark what
tuition and fees are sticker price and
discount on average oh yes um tuition
and fees net right
now $9,200 for
instate how about out
um I need to get you that commissioner
okay I have sticker price but I don't
have the discount all right what sticker
for
both I knew you were going to ask this
so I printed it before I came for every
in hang on just a second if I may while
she's looking that up uh I do serve as
the Senate president's appointment
appointe to University system board and
if you took out out of state students
right now with the infrastructure we
have and have to support you would
devastate the University system it would
go out of existence that quick well I I
hope I'm not implying that I don't like
out ofate students not at all okay
sticker
price
UNH tuition instate
155 out of state 30 I'm rounding
362 and that's just tuition just tuition
both okay
cool and we discount when I say
discount financial aid on average we
45% so on average right an instate
student across University system is
paying
$9,200 for tuition and fees after
financial
aid okay thank
now thank you very much Chancellor thank
you and good afternoon representative
wer good to see you congratulations on
your re-election thank you good to see
congratulations hey with that I'd like
to invite up the community college
you good afternoon chanceler good
afternoon director
Gary thank you for the opportunity to
speak with you but let me start by just
saying thank you as Chancellor
preventure pointed out we know this is a
challenging bium that we're approaching
and frankly I'm grateful for the budget
that has been provided to us as a
starting point for this
conversation uh with apologies it won't
prevent me from asking for opportunity
to see the state make additional
Investments that I think are in the best
interest of the work that we do for
students in the state of New Hampshire
uh I will take you through this slide
deck as efficiently as I can please you
feel free to stop me at any point that
it's helpful U cons referring back to
some of the questions that folks were
asking in the session with chancell
preven you'll note that we start 93% of
the students that we serve are New
Hampshire residents and for those of you
who are familiar with the Upper Valley
Sea Coast the North country you know
that the boundaries are a little bit
permeable in terms of Workforce and
students flowing back and forth so not
going to claim 100% New Hampshire but
that 93 is a probably a little bit of an
understatement for the impact that we
have in the regions that border New
Hampshire campuses throughout the state
our work is embedded locally in large
part because the students we serve need
that although about 30% of our
instruction is occurring online these
days majority of our students are
working adults and the ability for them
to participate as part-time students
primarily in courses that are accessible
to them where they live where they work
is essential it's part of what what
makes the community college system work
about 24,000 students served last year
notably about 10,000 of those are
students who are in high school
participating in Early College in
sometimes participating through their
high schools in some cases online and
other cases physically on our campuses
and I'll come back to Early College a
little bit
later slide three just drawing attention
to the fact that that we see our role as
a resource for the state as a partner uh
paying attention to what Bea Department
of Labor New Hampshire employment
security identify as needs of the state
as Chancellor preventure remarked at the
beginning of her presentation uh you'll
see the community college system
referenced in the recently report
released report regarding Advanced
manufacturing and the opportunity for uh
that as a critical sector in the state's
future our
Mission access affordability high
quality uh Partnerships with businesses
and communities throughout New Hampshire
ensuring the success of our students
with a skilled Workforce that's critical
economy I'm going to move past a couple
of the uh slides that are primarily just
uh background material Ju Just to remind
you the students we serve that that
issue of partnership with employers I'll
come back to momentarily but uh would
like to uh speak specifically to our
budget priorities on slide
eight controlling the cost of Education
affordability is a critical piece of
access for the students we serve and
previous discussion with Chancellor
proventure a lot of discussion about
financial aid the Fiasco debacco
whatever the word of the day is for what
happened with the roll out of the new
FAFSA disastrous for a lot of students
and Families Our effort is to try and
protect students interest better by
helping to manage costs at the front end
of that and I I'll come back to that in
our early college discussion but I also
want to acknowledge the fact that the
state has been an absolutely critical
partner we've Frozen tuition for six
years but we've kept it virtually flat
$5 increase since 2011 primarily through
the partnership the support the state
has provided but also
through essential financial management
happening at each of our campuses and in
the system office I I'll probably be
redundant something I referenced later
over the past 10 years we have reduced
our Workforce by about 30% some of that
is consistent with the downturn
enrollment but part of it is becoming
more efficient as an organization our
Personnel costs in fiscal 14 were about
95 million $94 million actually uh this
past year about $76 million obviously
we're dealing with the same inflationary
pressures we also want to Value the
workforce that contributes to the
success of our students and to the
viability of of our programs so have
been good stewards of State resources
and student resources as well as
philanthropic support to assist in
managing cost at the front end
Partnerships with New Hampshire's
employers later in this slide deck
you'll see a couple of of slides
hundreds of employers with whom we work
that's a list of current Partnerships
and engagement through our
apprenticeship New Hampshire program and
through our business training centers
located on each of our campuses to work
with employers to address critical needs
uh in those communities some large some
small but all essential to the to the
and if I could take you to uh slide
uh the house bill won the uh budget we
were presented over the summer
63,600 n, effectively flat which we
understand in this environment is
actually something for which we're
grateful we know that many agencies were
facing significant reductions in this
bium at the start and we appreciate the
the willingness to support the question
is posed does the efficiency budget fund
all current operations the the short
answer is no that it will require us to
continue to manage expenses and figure
out how to ensure that we can meet the
commitments we have to our faculty and
staff who support our students to
address the increases in health care and
on slide
13 a small number of critical priorities
areas that we hope the state will find
resources to continue to invest in the
number one priority that we're
identifying is duel and concurrent
enrollment this is the 10,000 students
we served in high schools last year the
state for 3 Bia the last three Bia has
been making this investment beginning
first with a million dollars in the most
was Reason by at $2.5 million a year for
that $2.5 million a year in the past
bium last year students earned
54,000 credits and our tuition fee rates
that's about $13 million of value the
return on that investment to the state
it shows up in the hands of students and
families throughout New Hampshire and if
we can continue to grow that we can
alleviate at least to some degree the
barriers of cost and the burden of debt
that becomes a problem for New Hampshire
families does not make them have to
worry as much about whether the FAFSA is
functioning the way it was intended to
less likely to to need loans long
term the additional opportunity with
duel and concurrent enrollment House
Bill 1530 passed two years ago is the
pathway Bill Chancellor preventure
remarked on the fact that we have now
between the two system systems developed
about a 100 Pathways for students to go
through the Community College to the
university
system if we anchor those programs with
Early College while students are still
in high school not only do we help
students manage the cost of high
education but the opportunity
particularly knowing that New Hampshire
tends to export a lot of its high school
graduates to out of state schools if we
can build relationships with those
students and those families while
they're still in high school increase
the likelihood that more of those
students stay home here in New Hampshire
long-term benefit to the workforce of
the state long-term benefit to those
students and their families so that is
our first priority because we think it
has the greatest impact on
affordability the second opportunity has
to do with continuing to keep tuition
Frozen as I said the state has been an
incredible partner has allowed us to
keep tuition virtually flat since
2011 even with that we're still in the
top four in the country for the cost of
Community College tuition we bump up
against Maine on the east coast and
Maine keeps tuition incredibly
affordable but all three of the states
that we border have put significant
dollars into financial aid programs for
Community colleg is often free Community
College which creates some pressure
again it's not necessarily drawing our
students away because most of our
students are location bound they're
part-time students they're not going out
of state to go to college but from an
employer perspective in figuring out
State's Investments and the climate for
Workforce Development it's an
opportunity for us to to maintain a
competitive Advantage keep New Hampshire
uh at the front of
that Workforce credentials in the last
banum legislature made some Investments
allowing us to introduce short-term
programs that were Workforce critical a
lot of our campuses introduced LNA and
and Med licensed nursing assistant
medical assistant programs CDL training
carpentry programs that would be in
critical need for Employers in the area
and for many of those programs what we
try to do is use that as seed money to
make those programs self sustaining we
think there's an opportunity to continue
to develop and iterate new programs that
are in need for the State uh and and
finally on that you'll see math learning
communities my understanding I this
predates my time with the community
college system is that there was grant
funding for math learning communities
intended to strengthen the work of Math
teachers in high schools allowing them
to strengthen the success of students in
high schools that has been brought back
representative lad was the champion of
funding for that initiative we took some
time to find a a a lead for that program
they launched at the end of this past
summer with 48 High School teachers will
continue to grow that program the person
who's leading that efforts currently
part-time uh the request for that
funding is to grow that to a full-time
role to expand the work that's being
done for the math learning communities
in New
Hampshire on slide 14 um just a couple
of highlights again enrollment has
stabilized about 2 and a half to 3%
increase last year summer and fall this
year again about 3% a little too early
to save for spring this begins to see a
turn in the what had been a long-term
Trend in declining enrollment for
community colleges the rebound that
we're seeing we think has legs to it the
affordability the value proposition of
community colleges the ability to reach
adult Learners in their communities but
also the ability to reach high school
students and increase their their
engagement we we see opportunity there
we have done as I said earlier a good
deal of work to try and and bring that
enrollment back but our our priority in
all of this is to ensure the quality of
these
programs last year between our RN
programs and our LPN programs about 300
nurses prepared for New Hampshire New
Hampshire for the sixth year in a row
the highest firsttime enlex pass rate
for nurses in the country that
commitment to Quality represented in all
of our programs and as our portfolio of
programs increas inly concentrated in
technical programs healthcare related
programs only becomes more important
that we not allow the the the quality of
those programs to suffer um budget
management as I mentioned earlier 30%
reduction the workforce over a decade
managing the cost of of all of our
operations currently looking at how
we're structured not necessarily
thinking about merger in the
conventional sense but really figuring
out where the offic icies are how do you
distinguish between things that are
critical in communities that are student
facing and public serving in each region
of the state and what kinds of things
can we do more consistently make the
opportunities both more efficient to
operate but also more seamless for
students who may want to navigate across
multiple
campuses overview of of Revenue and
and then Final on slide 16 Ju Just to
acknowledge our board's responsibility
as delegated by the legislature is to
provide a well-coordinated system of
public community college education we
draw from trustees experience in
Industries and sectors across the state
as well as the public interest and we
believe that the board remains an
excellent Steward on behalf of the state
for what we regard as a public resource
for New Hampshire and I'll stop and see
what questions I can
answer thank you Chancellor uh quick
question on on page 13 your additional
prioritized needs were were they
submitted as part of your
budget they were not we followed the
direction that we had been given as with
Chancellor preventure we received clear
indication to
submit uh
without okay
thank you and I was wondering if you
could um talk a little bit because we we
uh Chancellor preventure just touched on
it the the governor's task force on
higher education uh
specifically if the recommendations of
that task force are are are reacted uh
how will that uh affect you
financially depends on which
recommendations you might recall there
probably about 40 or so bullet points on
there uh the ones and and Chancellor
prevention I have been submitting
reports for first a quarterly report
more recently a first annual report on
this there are a handful of priorities
and among those uh Early College
investment we think is is potentially
valuable again to some degree it's not
financially beneficial to us as much as
it is to New Hampshire students and
families for the value that the state
transfers into their hands and for the
education we're able to provide them um
some of the other proposed uh changes
have to do with uh technology we're
looking at introducing uh a platform
that will help students navigate the
pathways that have been created make it
more sensible for degree planning
increase the likelihood that students
can use the information that's available
to them in ways that are constructive we
think those things will be helpful to us
in terms of growing enrollment U and and
fulfilling our
mission okay and my last question is on
actually on your curriculum and how you
deal with the business Community sorry
how you deal with the business Community
um has your curriculum changed to meet
the needs of the business Community
which I think have changed pretty
dramatically over the last 10 years or
so it it does virtually all of our
technical programs healthc care programs
have industry advisory boards working
closely with business and industry to
make sure that we're delivering what
they need for their Workforce our
apprenticeship New Hampshire hundreds of
apprenticeships have been initiated over
the last several years and many of those
are customized to the specific needs
that business and industry have that a
particular employer or occupation
requires supplemented with uh with
appropriate classroom
instruction but primarily focused on the
experiential components that that
employers value the hard skills that
that they need um in some cases ba
systems an excellent illustration the
microelectronics boot camp that was
developed in Partnership between BAE
Systems and Nashville Community College
work that's being done at Manchester
Community College for welding for
Cadia again industry tells us what they
need we figure out with the good grace
of of talented faculty how to deliver
programs that align with those
needs uh thank you sorry I lied because
I said I do have one more question uh
what percentage of your students are New
Hampshire residents are in state 93% is
our best uh figure it it varies a little
bit and among campuses closer border
versus Central although again 93% is a
safe number to work with okay and I'm
and I'm guessing that uh those students
you may not have this data but those
students once they graduate they tend to
stick home Dome we we we are we are work
with New Hampshire employment security
to have stronger clear data on the
outcomes for our graduates but
relatively confident that you will find
their here at home as I mentioned
earlier the majority of our students are
working adults as an
illustration two two median age of our
uh undergraduate population let let me
do this differently focus on the nursing
students 2third of those are in that 25
and older category one in five already
has a bachelor's degree in some other
field before they enter our nursing
program most of those folks are embedded
in the communities where they live
they're taking care of Children and
Families in those homes and they're not
going
anywhere thank
youor uh I wanted to give you the
opportunity to talk about an event
you're going to have on the 15th in your
relationship between the business
communities uh over at nhti well tra
trade po Mike R many of you will know
from his dirty job series is going to be
here governor elect aot I think is going
to be uh with us for the festivities we
expect probably 3, to 3500 people
joining us that day it's an opportunity
to remind young people and slightly less
young people what the opportunities are
what the needs are for occupations that
that often get overlooked and and are
are are critical for for all of us so
it's a it's a big event and and probably
as Lively an opportunity to be on the
nhdi campus and although I'm told
tickets are sold out and not wanting to
Curry favor with legislators or staff
who support legislators I'm sure we
could find a way in the back door if you
need
to representative
well one thing I think is worthy of
observing and I hope it's still the case
I've been a few times visiting the
campuses and I was impressed with the
fact that they get truckloads of brand
new vehicles contributed so that the
students are being trained on the latest
Vehicles the same thing with outboard
motors and printing presses those still
relationships still ongoing I'm very
impressed with that as a lasting Legacy
of Paul
Holloway and and the friendship that he
and Anna Grace have had with the
community college system New Hampshire
auto deals Association is an
extraordinary partner continues to
provide Vehicles in-kind support for
equipment and about $100,000 a year in
scholarships for students who are
participating in automotive technology
programs as we continue to develop um
our U EV programs in parallel with our
traditional uh Automotive programs we
continue to work closely with NADA and
and it's it's a great illustration of
what business in postsecondary education
like um I oh I'm not supposed to move
this close to me I'm too loud apparently
um what's your tuition roughly it's
$215 a credit and a $25 credit
enrollment fee and what's that how did
if I were to annualize that what that
$7,200 gives me an opportunity to
highlight that one of the benefits of
the state's longstanding commitment is
that by keeping tuition effectively flat
since 2011 in 20 in in 2012 2013 the
value of Federal pel grant was about
$4,600 which meant that a full-time
student at any of our campuses would
still need to find over
$2,000 over time as the value of that
pel Grant has now Eclipse tuition
$739 through that partnership a student
who's pel eligible I is is covered fully
by federal funds now majority of our
students are part-time so the example is
not a perfect one and and for many of
our students who are not pel eligible
it's still out of pocket that they're
paying so it's the reason we maintain
our interest in affordability can you be
pel eligible and go part-time you can
but only to to Half Time
oh okay I'm below a certain threshold
the enrollment isn't there and and I
should note that again this is for
credit-based
programs increasingly we see our work in
Workforce focused programs that are
often not eligible for p uh
participation it's one of the places
where Congress has stumbled for years to
be able to
overcome that barrier of how students
really need to learn and what the
workforce really needs versus how
federal aid is handled I will say that
we've benefited from weoa the workforce
Innovation Opportunity Act funding and
partnership with folks like Joe Doran
director doran's been a helpful partner
in supporting students in many of our
programs for which we owe a funding is
the is the better option maybe you can
talk to your friend Mike Ro to call
Congress and see if he can do something
about that um you and I talked in the
past about um you have dorms at nhti and
you have less and less need for dorm
students at nhti have you done any more
looking I was driving by the other day
and I'm looking you know there's that
road that sort of dead ends in the
circle yep and I was thinking it'd be a
great spot for housing so e even e even
today we have 3,000 students enrolled at
nhti we have about 300 beds in the three
residential buildings buildings one of
those buildings is actually leased to um
uh New Hampshire hockey Academy it's a
partnership that they have with a local
high school for students who aspire to
continue their secondary school
education while polishing their their
hockey skills perhaps for future uh
college scholarship opportunities or
Beyond so we've made good use of one of
those three buildings that that had
capacity and will continue to try and
figure out what's the best use of
welcome uh thanks Chancellor U I was
actually happy to introduce that bill a
while ago but they still haven't passed
it but they should um I have a quick
question about the Dual and concurrent
enrollment as you've looked at the the
um you know the stabilizing of your
student body and then the light uptick
how important has that if you have like
if I'm in high school and I receive for
example credit hours are you seeing
those students transition to the
community college and continue on I'm
just curious if you have data on that so
yes and no so
uh we looked at 2016 to 2022 students
who participated in our Early College
Programs to have some sense of what the
flowthrough looked like and of about
35,000 students served over that period
of time almost 28,000 went to
postsecondary education now of that
group about 6,000 came to the community
college system about 6,600 ended up at
the University system the majority of
these students ended up at four-year
institutions and the majority of those
students at for year institutions
actually went out of state so that's why
I said if we can tie this to House Bill
1530 to help introduce students not only
to the academic Pathways but introduce
them to our faculty to our facilities I
think we can encourage more New
Hampshire students and their families to
look seriously at staying in New
Hampshire to complete the degrees that
are now made more seamless more
affordable and and more clearly
available to them what we expect to see
over time is that if we can reach more
students for whom college is an
aspiration but not a certainty that we
can have more students who will come to
the community college system but our
experience is the majority of students
participating in Early College these are
honors level courses it's either AP or
it's honors or they're taking these
early college courses these are students
who already know they're going to
college that's the aspiration and we
think that if we could make this more
accessible to that next group of
students for whom college is less
certain and for whom affordability is a
greater concern we think we would see
more of these students actually take
advantage of the opportunities to come
to the community college system and not
not everybody necess necessarily needs
College in the way we traditionally
think of a four-year degree or Beyond
but the building blocks of most of our
programs whether it ties into the
related instruction to support an
apprenticeship whether it's somebody
who's heading into one of the trades but
gets that foundational set of credits
and skills that are in the bank for them
both literally and figuratively for
somebody who's thinking about going into
the military but doesn't want to feel
like they're losing ground with peers
who are going directly to college we can
give students in all of those Avenues a
foundation of SEC postsecondary learning
that that's money in the bank it's a
foundation of academic success that they
can build on regardless of which
direction they choose to take it thank
much like to invite up now the New
good afternoon good afternoon members of
the committee
um I'm Charlie McIntyre I have the
privilege of being the director
Hampshire Lottery and with me is our CFO
Jim
dur um I only have one
slide and it's the last 10 years of
revenues transfers and
expenses and you'll note from fy15 to
fy4 that the expenses of the lottery
have gone up
66% and at the same time the
profitability of the lottery has gone up
three-fold uh whenever in private sector
you get to do 66% expense growth and
three times Revenue growth that's called
better than good um regrettably it has
not been reflected on our salaries we
hope that to change in the near
future um but obviously we're a
self-funded agency we've had 10-year
growth our growth is not only remarkable
in the sense
of its size but by comparison other
lotteries uh we're the fastest growing
lottery in North
America um and not only that growth has
obviously helped the state with funding
but also the retail Network our
commission retail network has more than
doubled its commission rates in similar
time not only does it help them in terms
of money to the stores but also every
dollar of lottery sales at a store is
accompanied by $3 of sales of something
else candy bar soda gas Etc
um notably we are either at or near the
top of every single metric that is
measured in our business and that means
every product every sale every
profitability efficiencies and the rest
and so um while our budget is um
significant it is essentially
self-funded there's no money the state
sends us we spend Revenue stream and
send you their profitability so um I
expect to give you guys some time back I
don't expect to take all 20 minutes but
certainly happy to answer any questions
you have regarding our budget sure thank
you very much um more of a of a comment
that on the sin taxes that the state
collects whether drinking smoking and
gambling uh we've seen uh drinking go
down smoking go way down but but
gambling is thriving um and the the
state is the benefactor of that one of
uh my question two years ago when we
were discussing it Massachusetts was
about to introduce sports sports game
Sports gambling and uh they have since
done that uh we were concerned I think
rightly so that it would impact our
Sports gambling apparatus how is that
materialized and and what's been the
impact of of not only competition for
Massachusetts but other states across
the na as well it's a good question
certainly when I hear frequently I think
it's about a 15% drop in Revenue uh I
can't assess the other side I can only
tell you that the most popular places in
the state for a while to bet on Sports
were the Portsmith traffic circle and
the Mall of New Hampshire so folks were
coming up betting on sports going to the
liquor store and then going to shop
taxfree I don't know if what impact it's
had on that the retail side but for us
about a 15% drop um the last full year
we had Mass players kept driving up here
it was about $38 million of profit
ability I think last year sports betting
was like 32 32 million so not you know
15 16% okay is football still the
driver football and the basketball
tournament the NCA tournament okay uh
and we lost more re we lost more sports
book physical Sports Book Sales we had a
number of large betters who drove up
from Massachusetts to play at the brook
um and C Brook and um Manchester they
sto coming up and they're going out of
Boston but they were frankly more
talented at it so our margin wasn't very
good so we we lost customers but we lost
ones we didn't want anyway and finally
does is sports betting especially
football betting in the state of New
Hampshire is that dependent on how well
the Patriots do like is there more
interest in betting on sports if if the
if the team is is good or better like
the The Fringe better there there is
more interest certainly but sometime
that's that's a detriment like we had a
really bad NBA season last year because
the Celtics were really good and they
kept covering and so it was it was not
helpful but it's helpful when the team
is good it's we always want the local
team to win but not cover it's it makes
being a fan
you I like that um I have a couple of
questions um your in terms of
profitability um scratch
tickets most profitable thing we have
largest yes in in terms of total
toal profit total uh I think it was 68
just based on scratch tickets yeah right
in there 68 million so with um the
margin on a scratch ticket is around 18
half percent margin and so theoretically
in out of your 200ish scratch tickets
are about
68 68% payout you mean no$ 68 million
yeah a profitability yes and then what's
second uh second would be the joint
Powerball megail Millions type product
game last year we did N I think it was
91 million in the sales that's a 40%
margin so that's about 36 37 million
profitability for that um then would be
sports betting at 32 um our ey Lottery
platform is right there about 30 and
then everything falls off of those those
are what we call tent
poles oh tent poles okay um you're so
this year I mean you're you know step
step step up hockey stick you call it um
this year you're down a few million
through four months yeah so um over
prior year over no over prior yeah not
not as against plan but a prior year
well no but the plan was just a really
bad
estimate no what I meant is you're doing
really well correct what it is is last
year we started the year with two very
very large jackpots over a billion
dollars and we haven't had those this
year and it makes my job really easy if
in August we have multiple jackpots but
if we don't have them for a while I have
to pray to the jackpot Gods uh and so
that's that drives that much business oh
yeah oh sure there are times we will do
in Powerball sales we'll
do more than half our business in 13
days for a year and so it's this the
we'll do millions and millions and
millions in a day and sales it it
matters the frenzy once it hits the
media once there's water cooler talk
once you drive by the billboard and it
says billions yeah it's very much um
like a three foot snowstorm shows up
when it shows up so the next time I see
a billboard that says a billion I should
change the state revenue estimates
ballpark no not necessarily and also one
the one of the interesting Parts is is
that um the jackpots are a factor of the
bond factor and so our cash on hand is
multiplied by a bond factor which is
affected by interest rates so as
interest rates Rose our jackpots got
higher even though the cash value was
yeah
okay representative congratulations keep
up to good work thank you thank you
representative see no more questions
you and now I like to uh bring up the
good afternoon commissioner good
afternoon for the record and I just want
to thank you for putting Charlie ahead
of me um and I can confirm based on his
testimony that our budget will be okay
uh given how he's done and I will also
mention Charle that um I'm one of those
when I see the B number in front of the
the Powerball I buy a ticket so I'm one
of those uh people jumping in there um
so appreciate the opportunity to present
this to you uh you know our vision a
mission for uh the Department of
Education is to live free and learn um
with a very student centered approach to
create Bright Futures for all students
um our objective here is interesting as
well that I got to follow usnh as well
as uh the community college system uh
because we are basically connecting up
those systems we are preparing students
uh that can hopefully uh some of which
anyways will have a successful
post-secondary career and at either UNH
uh Plymouth State Keen State College or
one of our community college systems
across or schools across the state um
it's interesting as well as those indivi
those systems are trying to figure out
what the future looks like I can confirm
for you today that the class of
2036 which will be eligible to go to
postsecondary started school in
September so we pretty much know plus or
minus a very small percentage of how
many of those students we have in the
system that will be um matriculating
into one of our universities system you
know schools um the budget submission
that you have before you uh meets the
governor's parameters that he gave us
which was about a 3.3% reduction uh
versus the 25 adjusted authorization
that we were given um those of you who
have seen our budget presentations
before are familiar probably with our
page one um I realize that the numbers
are small I could make them smaller and
add more years but um I try not to do
that to your eyes but we have laid out
for you kind of in one
piece of paper you got a snapshot of how
where the money comes in and where the
money goes out um you will see at the
top we have Revenue our funding comes
from General funds federal funds
education trust fund inter agency
transfers and then some other funds that
we receive through fees or other revenue
streams uh we have also put on there the
local education Ed spending that takes
place um you know in the state of New
Hampshire we have the state contribution
um and then we have a local contribution
through our local property taxes and so
you can see the amount of local property
taxes or contributed to the K12 system
um over the previous years uh We've also
included um District enrollment for the
adma um as well as average cost per
pupil uh we then summarize on this slide
our general funds um which is basically
general fund state aid which is uh
programs that the legislature has given
to the department uh for specific
targeted programs such as historically
they were uh things like Dropout
prevention or Statewide special
education Career Tech student orgs
building Aid lease uh lease Aid um I
will point out that there were you'll
you'll notice some of these line items
um have moved in previous
legislatures uh there were funds that
were previously either in general fund
state aid or in general funds passed
through that have been moved down into
the education trust fund um and so
you'll be able to see
that for the next bium those general
fund State a programs either have been
phased out or they have been been moved
down to the um uh the education trust
fund and out of general fund state aid
it is building Aid lease has been moved
down into uh the trust fund um when I go
to the next section general fund pass
through state aid these are funds that
are provided to the department uh which
essentially we receive and then we push
out to our schools or to other programs
um whether those are associated with
court order placements which again is
not showing um in the current proposal
because it's been moved down into the
education trust fund um and then uh
assessments as well has been moved down
into the education trust fund um the
other thing that I want to point out
with respect to some of these general
fund Amounts is as you get into the
budget process and if you begin to
Tinker with those we have to be a little
bit sensitive because some of these
include match funds uh which are requ IR
ired in order to retain our federal
grants so these are the state
contribution the state match that allows
us to uh continue to participate in the
federal uh the related Federal match uh
you then have the general fund salary
and benefits so you can see the history
of salaries benefits and insurance and
our allocations from our uh other
organizations or other agencies in the
state and then you can see kind of a
layout of uh where the funds and the
education trust fund are going um and so
that is kind of a big picture and I'm
sure there's probably some questions
about that but I'll move through the
presentation and then probably come back
to that to deal with questions um I
added a slide to this bm's uh
presentation about enrollment on slide
number two uh so that you had some
perspective um as to how enrollments are
trending in the State uh not you know
dissimilar from the comments that you
heard from the University system uh
somewhat from the community college
system while there serving a an older
population General generally and are not
as uh Sensi sensitive to direct student
you know K12 student populations um you
know the number of students in the state
of New Hampshire uh the demographic
shift continues and we expect um you
know out into the you know and I don't
want to go you know too far out but out
into the foreseeable future we believe
that the number of students in the state
of New Hampshire will continue to
decline and so we will continue we have
been for several decades now but we will
continue to um respond to those declines
in the delivery system on the next slide
titled FY 2425 hb2 Appropriations I just
wanted to flag for the committee uh some
of the 2023 or the 23 surplus funds that
were given to the department for
specific projects uh there was a
legislative process or project to um get
a hold of a license for the student
Clearing House data software so that we
are then able to uh run information and
provide to our
uh secondary schools the the direction
those students and if they go into a
post-secondary institution Vis title two
reporting to be able to uh track them
and see where they are so we're
providing that information we're able to
provide that information back to um the
secondary schools uh we received a
one-time allocation of $900,000 which
was uh directed at our Bureau of student
wellness um we received a Civics fund
education which is related to developing
curriculum for the um uh for civics K12
in the state of New Hampshire um those
funds have been committed and are we're
actively working on the development of
that curriculum and that's moving along
um we have received a $4 million grant
for uh and the the idea of trying to
expand the number of computer science
credentials in the state we've
implemented that program um the reality
is that there has not been a substantive
uptake of that program the name of
program is called upgrade um had a call
on it today but there's not been tons of
folks who have been coming out of the
woodwork who are in Industry seeking to
convert into the education profession um
in spite of uh you know quite a
significant Outreach effort um to a diff
a bunch of different um constituents um
we will in this budget in hb2 be seeking
language to use un uh committed amounts
of those funds this is non-aps funds we
have in there um for our program to
expand our dual and concurrent beyond
the community college system into the
university system so that students in
high school will be able to earn um
University of New Hampshire credits uh
you know while they're in high school so
really we do that already for the um you
know the Community College um and you
heard from the community college that uh
you know that that's an opportunity to
try and reach students who might not
otherwise be postsecondary bound to
engage them um but we also know that a
number of those credits transfer out of
state uh because those students who are
taking advantage of those dual and
concurrent programs are really seeking
four-year degrees in some institution
outside of State uh we believe that by
expanding those and we'll pilot this out
to the university system uh there's no
need to go out of state to a four-year
University because you can stay here at
UNH or Keen or Plymouth State and uh and
and transfer those credits there as well
so uh that is something we will be
looking for um the next item The Adult
Ed that you provided for us was $500,000
this is really for our adult ed programs
that uh really if you look at all of the
various covid relief programs that had
come out uh there was not one that was
targeted directly at um you know the
adult dead types of program so this was
to support many of those programs uh
across the state we've got 19 different
centers across the state and just to put
that into context it's referred to as
adult education um I tease the woman who
runs it Sarah Wheeler that she runs the
largest High School in the state of New
Hampshire uh because the adult dead
program serve uh over 1,700
uh 16 17 and 18yearold students who are
not participating in their uh assigned
high school and they're attaining their
high school diploma or GED through the
adult dead programs um you know
sometimes just too much drama over there
whatever it is but they've got so she
runs the largest High School in the
state of New Hampshire um in terms of
Education trust fund uh you'll see the
public school infrastructure fund uh
which was $10 million that we were
awarded and these have been targeted and
already appro at out to schools for
safety grants um we work with the uh the
public school infrastructure committee
um and our Focus really has been on
Access Control emergency alerting and
surveillance systems we work very
closely with the Department of Homeland
Security uh to turn this around and
continue to um make those Investments
and making sure that our students and
our staff are safe in our school
settings um and I would just want to say
thank you to the legislature because uh
in the years that I've been in this
position the legisl has uh provided well
over $50 million towards safety um in
the school system and you will see in my
budget again I'm I have uh you know a
line item for another $10 million 5
million each year uh to continue that
safety work because I think it needs to
be an ongoing investment and not
episodic we've not we've been uh
fortunate to not have any um serious
Adverse Events in the state of New
Hampshire I want to keep it that way uh
and I think an ongoing focus and
attention on this rather than a a a
reactionary approach is a better
approach for that and I appreciate the
legislature supporting that um we have a
uh a grant that the legislature provide
us through one-term grants to support
tuition and transportation for our CTE
centers uh to again open up additional
opportunities to afford schools to be
able to um you know uh if if cost was a
barrier of getting kids to uh Career and
Technical education programming that
this grant would help overcome that
obstacle I would tell you that that's
not our number one obstacle but it is an
important one um and so there is an open
grant for schools to be able to apply
when they have excess costs um that are
not reimbursed either through the normal
formula or through their local school
district and they want to seek
reimbursement for that they're able to
do that um kindergarten Aid is just uh a
line item that you all have given us for
a number of years or a number of budget
Cycles at this point in time which is
for those students um those children who
have been in half day programs and then
a school dist District maybe opens up a
full day kindergarten program and so
this is a supplement to that additional
tuition that would uh take place in that
first year it's a onetime item um we
also received funding last year for a
new program uh episodes of treatment uh
a couple by anyo you all pass the
program the fast forward program which
allows HHS to intervene uh when there's
an acute mental illness uh issue for a
particular student uh when that happens
there is uh uh cost Associated often
times with a um kind of a a deployment
or a placement of a child in some type
of an alternative setting while they're
through that recovery process and so
these are funds that we coordinate with
HHS to be able to uh provide for the
education of those students who are um
you know temporarily displaced from
their maybe resident District or
whatever other placement they're in if
they have to go to a special placement
uh until they get stabilized and can
join back in to our school settings and
then the last two items which I think
are important for the legislature to be
considering is uh two CTE projects um
you know Sugar River for 12.5 wi Squam
for 6 7.6 million um historically these
projects have been funded through the
capital budget uh in this last banian
budget they were not they were included
as uh one-time projects of surplus funds
um but I can tell you that at present I
have three uh you know proposed CTE
Renovations coming that will probably
come before for you um they've not all
been approved locally by their uh their
communities but those are activities
that are being worked on um they are
larger projects uh they the they amount
to close to $60 million which would
probably be the highest number the
highest value of the projects that I've
seen since I've been in this role um but
those will be coming and and should be
something to consider because if the you
know without this year they these CTE
projects again historically in the
capital budget not in this last capital
budget but we'll probably come back to
that capital
budget on the next slide I just wanted
to focus um a couple of items for
prioritized needs that were included in
our uh budget uh the first two are
really administrative um you know
Department of administrative Services
asked us to include a a um a rent item
as a prioritized needs do doit had us
put a placeholder down there for a
dollar I'm going to guess that if they
do charge me it's going to be more than
a dollar I hope not but I don't know um
and then the other two that I'm going to
flag for you is uh you know we've had
we've been flush with covid cash for a
number of years um as a result of the
pandemic and we've been able to uh you
know carry forward a number of different
uh educational programs in the state to
be able to um support the schools and
try and encourage and help make up lost
learning that took place uh these
included things like a letters program
which is uh training over 5,000
Educators and early childhood uh workers
in the science of reading to make sure
that our students are getting making
progress there um there was a program
called rekindling curiosity uh every kid
was able to uh go to Camp kind of thing
uh for it started out as a program for
disabled uh or for uh low-income
students to be able to get to Camp uh we
partnered in that program with the
community Behavioral Health Association
and we're able to provide a number of
mental health support services to
students and families in our camps
throughout the state and was a very uh
successful program uh we had tutor.com
so that every student in the state of
New Hampshire had access to 247 tutoring
Services we've got kigo which is an
artificial intelligence online platform
that accelerates and assists teachers
and students in their Learning Classroom
uh but two that I've included here in
our um you know prioritize needs one is
a learning platform so this is for
Discovery education so Discovery
Education was high quality instruction
materials that we rolled out to uh
schools in the pandemic mic what we saw
initially in the pandemic was some
schools were able to provide high
quality materials other schools were
still sending home manila envelopes that
really were less high quality um and we
wanted to make sure that all of our
students had access to high quality uh
instruction materials we rolled this
program out um and what we saw
relatively quickly is that
100% of New Hampshire public schools are
using the discovery platform at this
point in time um and I would tell you
that I say this somewhat factiously so
don't anybody be offended by the joke I
could offer gold bars to my schools and
some would say like nah we're good here
we don't have any place to store them
right so the fact that 100% of the
schools are using a platform I mean it
communicates to me uh that this is a
platform that is valued U by the
districts um clearly because we're
providing them uh you know curricular
materials there's a degree of offset I
don't know what that degree is because
it happens very locally um but we are
supporting them with this platform and
we're and so I'm I'm continuing uh
seeking continu funny for that and then
the next item is really uh State
assessment funding um so today we do
assessments for students uh federally
required in grades 3 through eight and
then again once in high school and we
provide that once in high school is the
SAT that the students participate in in
11th grade the difficulty with that is
that you don't really have very good
trajectory information you don't know
how those students are progressing um we
think that a PSA or a similar instrument
because I'm not I don't want to be uh
bound to a particular uh vendor or
instrument but a you know kind of a
ninth grade assessment would give uh
students or give Educators and
administrators trajectory information on
how those students are doing right
because if you give the kid the test in
11th grade and you get that result at
the end of the 11th grade and they're
they're behind it's really hard to
scramble and make that up in one year
it's just not going to happen right so
we need better information I think would
be useful um it was interesting I spoke
with um the superintendent from one of
our largest school districts in the
state today and we were having a
conversation about this they themselves
are already running this so a number of
the schools have recognized the value
associated with doing this um and again
this is one of those programs I want to
make sure it's not one of those halves
and have not the school districts have
the ability to do something like this
and get good information about the
progress of their students academic
achievement are doing it and others are
not um so that is why is it it is been
has been listed as a prioritized need um
the next and last slide that I will
present to you is really um we currently
have 306 full-time positions um we are
requesting 10 new position requests and
this is uh these are all federally
funded this is in our disability
determination Services Bureau um and you
may for those of you who have seen a few
of these budgets we've actually
increased this I've expanded I get
nervous every time I see these headcount
numbers go up right but essentially
what's happening is we're doing a good
job for the federal government we
basically are a service center to the
Social Security Administration uh we
provide the adjudication for uh
disability determinations uh they like
the work that they are that we are doing
and so this would be we just recently
got another request to increase our
capacity to provide more support
services uh when they do that they
increase our funding they pay for these
additional stuff so over the years uh
they've come to us three times now and
said can you do more work for us and so
uh those new 10 positions are uh
positions that are requested um for that
work and that is in the budget um and so
with that I will pause and take
questions that you may
have thank you commissioner first I just
want to like uh go over a couple of
figures uh which I which I think tell a
a a interesting story here yeah uh that
you present uh from 2020 to 2024 local
spending has gone from 3.2 billion up to
3.86 billion uh State spending from the
education trust fund has gone from 1
billion to 1.25 billion which is about a
15% increase that state the local
increase was about 12% but meanwhile uh
enrollment has fallen from 163,000 to
151,000 or
6.7% decrease and that's meant that the
average cost per pup has grown from
16,000 roughly to uh over 21,000 per
person my question is why is education
expenditures going up so much and I'm
going to sort of borrow a question that
that commissioner Arling house asked
earlier and that is the relationship
between
administrative and teachers uh is this
money being spent on teachers or
administrators and what have you seen in
the ratio between those two over the
last five 10 years yes so there have
been um several studies that have taken
place independent studies that have
looked at that and what you have seen is
an increase in the percentage of
Administrators um in the school
buildings uh those administrators
include uh your traditional
administrative roles such as uh you know
like we've got superintendant maybe uh
assistant superintendents or principles
and assistant principles again that same
um you know admin superintendent from
one of our larger systems that I was
talking to today uh you know is looking
for opportunities to to to move this
down and was indicating that there's a
lot of resistance uh they were hoping to
have uh you know to cons have have two
systems that they've seen the number
these are these are two buildings that
are already connected it's a middle
school and a elementary school and in
the midle school and Elementary School
they've seen the number of students come
down considerably but each the middle
school and the elementary school in
buildings that are connected have each
has a principal each has a system
principles and they're thinking like can
we just have one principal and then an
assistant principal over each um and and
the the superintendent I was speaking
with expressed a great deal of
frustration that there was a lot of
resistance uh among the staff uh to be
able to do something like that so so I I
don't have specific uh information to
share with you but I do know that there
have been some thirdparty studies that
have indicated a shift in terms of the
um you know the number of Administrators
to the number of Staff uh you know in
some of our buildings um but there have
been an increase relative to some of the
non-traditional administrative roles as
well you're seeing a higher number of
you know school counselors you're um you
know you're seeing a higher number of
school psychologists you're seeing a
higher number of welfare um support
staff that are in the schools as the
schools uh you know some some sometimes
by default because those students are
there are taking over functions um and
supporting those kids with the objective
of trying to ensure that learning is
taking place but um you know if I knew
the answer to why the cost the per pupil
cost of education is uh is going up like
that um like that's The $64,000 Question
I would put that number on that
Powerball the next time I at a billion
dollar so I would be there uh
so um so we see that happening but
another aspect of it that you have to
consider is that what we have is a
system that has a high degree of fixed
cost in its system um and a reducing
number of students is obviously then
going to result you know mathematically
in a higher number of cost per pupil
right so we have uh sometimes to be able
it's going to be necessary to make more
and more uh harder and difficult
decisions in communities to be able to
uh make sure that we've got a system
that fits the constituent that we're
going to be serving and I don't think
that that's unique to the K12 system I
think that applies to the community
college system I think it applies the
university system as well um that
they've got large fix fixed cost
campuses um and the number of students
like I said my class of 2036 started
kindergarten this year right so we know
how many of these kids are going to show
up plus or minus a very small variation
so we should be planning for that future
um and I think that you know it's
important to be up optimistic but it's
also important to be realistic and
understand kind of the realities of the
you hey how are you I'm good um I have a
couple of questions one is can you talk
talk me through building Aid yeah
there's a there's a tale from the money
we borrowed years ago and then are you
doing additional
expenses building Aid projects I don't
yeah so the way we were instructed in
our budgeting process to basically
include the tail here and then let the
legislators decide what it is that they
want to do relative building Aid so
you'll see if you go down to the bottom
building a is 1 2 3 4 five six seven
lines up and you cut across it's got uh
14, 762 and then 12 M39 those are tail
numbers so those are those so what was
the 43 last
year um so that was the appropriation
that we received and so do we do new
projects yeah we do have some building
projects that are ongoing and do they
have additional tail they don't have
tail no no we don't no this is all pay
as you go at this point in time the the
tail is I origin we're do we're not
doing over 10 years anymore no we don't
these are all this is pay as you go all
the projects that we've done for at
least the last eight years have been pay
as you go okay so like here's six
million take it yeah exactly right take
it or leave it and then if they don't
want it they we give it to the next
person in line so okay
um I have a question about lawsuits you
may have noticed that there have been
educ funding
lawsuits I think that could have been
set at every budget hearing for the last
40 years um but
um what happens do you have like what
happens if some of them
go you know some of the bigger lawsuits
could go this way or that way and do you
have contingency plans if they go this
way or that way um so we do I have to be
a little bit cautious because these are
uh ongoing legal matters that I'm I'm
I'm involved in obviously named in
lawsuits um but I can tell you that
there have been uh contingency plans
that have been discussed with the
legislature even as early as last spring
um there are uh you know things that can
be
done okay I guess I'll I guess I'll drop
it there at that point um and a question
I've been asking a bunch of agencies so
just to go back so if your question is
do I have an extra $500 million in this
budget I don't well it's not hidden in a
some line item okay I was guessing that
or else you didn't roll everything up
right prioritize
need um question I've been asking a
bunch of people is what if you so in the
so your general and your education funds
total anyway don't go down a lot um what
what if the budget situation um let's
just say the the the new governor coming
in um decides that where we are today is
not supported by the revenues that we
expect to have and and let's say you
have to cut an additional four or 5% out
of both the education trust fund and the
general fund have you started internal
discussions on what that would look like
so what I would I'd start with the fact
that we've already taken 4% out of our
budget year-over-year right so we've
already taken 4 per out I mean if you
tell me I have to go take another 4% out
then we will go take another 4% out um
that's my question yeah so I mean that's
really a function of the legislature the
legislature tells us what Target they
want us on and or the governor or the
governor right and we will meet that
Target but it it's my way of saying
let's say that came to pass yeah um it
would be good if you started internally
thinking about that well I mean I think
not next week so it's I don't think that
it's a function of thinking about that I
mean like we those um contingency
scenarios are ones that even as an
agency we're playing through in our
heads all along right like okay so what
if right okay the covor gives me a
certain Target and we have budgeted and
produced and delivered that Target uh
but then we also like you hypothetically
can say like okay suppose I got to take
another 5% out suppose I got to they
come back and he tells me I want another
5% above like I don't want it just to be
you don't if it's 5% more I don't want
that to be a capricious decision and a
and a knee-jerk reaction you want to be
very strategic about what it is that you
would invest those funds
in um good okay the other my last
question is related to there have been
some news reports uh recently about
there's some discussion in Washington
about taking a lot of the federal money
and uh I I don't know exactly what how
exactly they're talking about this but
what if they block granted it to the
states or something like that have you I
don't honestly think that's going to
come to pass because because of you know
politics but if it did happen have you
started thinking about that so we have
we've already started the the you know
again we also have no additional
information Beyond what you know but in
the event that we see received roughly
$270 million from the feds um I would
assume if they achieved the full extent
of their plan and uh were able to
eliminate the full Department of
Education I think that includes about
initial $2 billion doar of uh Personnel
cost related uh in DC I don't know if
that just becomes a cut or if that
becomes part of the Blan Grant but um
you know so we have begun the thought
process of what does it look like if
$270 million is block granted to the
state so that we would understand
strategically what would that what would
we want how how would that be directed
um and obviously it would be highly
contingent on the nature of the block
grant because even block grants come
sometimes with strings attached to them
in terms of how they can be deployed um
and what they might be deployed for um
but those we are thinking about them
good I
you thank you very much thank you
okay and with
that we are in recess until 8:30
tomorrow